Good. And you're good? Okay. All right.
We're going to go ahead and get started and call this meeting, our work session,
to order. It's 4:01. And Ben is
going to be here in just a minute. I think he's online for now until
he gets here. Okay. And also just wanted to point out we do
have a lot of closed session items to get through tonight
for the council's awareness. So I want to stick as close as we
can to these timelines, and we've told each of the presenters to make sure that
half the time's for the presentation and half the time's for some
discussion if that's the case. If there's something that requires more time,
then just let us know that we needed to
bring it back or something. But I want to try and make sure that we
can stay on track because we got a lot to do in, in a minute.
So. Thank you. With that in mind, I did move some things
around earlier, but I don't think it changed anything.
So we're gonna start off with 1D, discussion item 1D,
which is the Well-Being Project survey results.
So, Abby, were you gonna introduce?
Yes, thank you, Mayor. I just wanna introduce
Dr. Courtney Flint. She's a professor at Utah State University.
They did a well-being survey that was conducted in April 2021.
2026 of this year, and she's here to share the results, which I think are
really interesting. So I'm gonna turn the time over to her. Thank you for doing
this. Sure. Awesome. So great to be with you. It's great to
be partners again. We partnered with you on this project in 2020.
A lot's changed in Eagle Mountain since then, so it's fun to look
at the results. I'll hop right in. So the goals of the project, you know,
I'm from Utah State. We're the land-grant university. Any Aggies in the house?
Oh, we're far from Aggieland. Okay.
Well, it's great to be here. We really provide,
with the Utah Well-Being Project, a way to help you keep your
fingers on the pulse of how your residents are doing, inform your planning processes
and decision-making. We do some research on the data related
to well-being, and we support statewide and regional initiatives. We work closely with
health districts, Department of Health, Department of Transportation,
Office of Planning and Budget, things like that.
As you can see from the map, we are all up and down the Wasatch
Front and east and west and north and south across the
state. Our city reports from our 2026 surveys are online.
Yours is up on our website, so I encourage you to check that out if
you haven't already. So this is an online
survey. It is a no-cost partnership with you,
emphasis on the word partnership. This would not happen without us
working together because we provide the survey, We provide
some materials, but you do the recruitment. We figure cities know best how to reach
their residents, and we don't have the budget to do it any other way,
so this is how it works. You did participate in 2020.
You had 506 responses then, and you had 359
responses. These are all pretty comparable numbers
to other cities similar to you all.
We like to be— since it's not a proportionate representative sampling
effort, we like to be very transparent about who we
are reaching, and who we are not. So this graph here compares
the survey demographics with the demographics that we can see from recent
census data. The closer the dots are, and really you can
barely see that there are 2 dots in many of these places, what that means
is the closer the dots are means we have really,
really represented that particular demographic. So we've
done actually really well according— you look across income,
Most of the age categories here, employment and
homeowners and renters, those dots are overlapping. I mean,
that's just really incredible. We don't see that kind of correlation as well.
We do overrepresent those who are married, but we're
pretty darn close on most everything else. That 18 to
29-year-old age group is hard to reach anyway.
Mostly full-time residents, 50% have lived here for
5 years or less. Super high when you compare it to a
lot of our communities. Communities that are in the project. I should say there were
57 other— 56 other communities that we are reporting
on this spring. So let's dive into
the results. So personal well-being in Eagle Mountain, we compare the
group at the bottom are the rapid growth cities. We use the League of Cities
and Towns caucus groups,
and so that's what we've represented here.
You may or may not sort of feel comfortable there, although you are certainly rapidly
growing. Average of 3.92,
72% said a 4 or a 5. It ranks a
little bit low here in terms of comparing to other rapid growth
cities, but you're right there with other nearby neighbors in Saratoga
Springs and in Lehigh. You're all probably not even statistically significantly
different from each other. If you look at
the big scale and you think from all the way to the big cities to
the really small towns, you can see that there are a fair few— there's
some communities that are lower than Eagle Mountain. So don't get
too hung up on your positionality there in those rapid growth cities. And I think
we've got some good explanations for why that's the case where it is
at the moment. Community well-being, we see it always
declines for respondents. They often feel that others,
the community as a whole, is not doing as well as they are personally.
So we have the data here. 42% say
a 4 or a 5. Change over time since 2020. Now, we don't
know if it's the same group taking the survey or not, but if
you look on average here, you can see that well-being has declined somewhat
since our 2020 survey data. We look beyond
these general categories and we dive into 12 different what we call domains
or categories of well-being. And this has been informed
by various federal and international agencies.
You can see that here in this graph, it shows us that the most important
well-being domains to the people of Eagle Mountain are mental
health, safety and security, living standards, and family life.
The highest-rated domains are family life, safety and security,
and mental health. So really strong alignment with those things
that matter most to folks are doing really well. So that is a that is
important. The red zone, which is those
things that are important to folks but rated a little lower than average,
we find leisure time and local environmental quality.
Now leisure time, we know that your largest
age group is actually in that 30 to 39-year-old range,
and that group, as we look across the state data, those people
are not the— don't have the highest well-being. In fact, they're really quite low,
and they're really, really busy. They're often raising families and working hard,
and so leisure time is a sparse commodity for that group. So that
may explain why that's there. Local environmental quality is the
most prominent red zone category around the
state. So we all, as a state, you're not alone in that position.
And as we look at these things over time, you can see that some of
them have declined ever so slightly. A couple more, education, local environmental
quality, have that deeper dip. over those 6
years. Safety and security has gone up just a tad.
Another thing we measure with the wellbeing survey is community connection.
How connected do you feel to Eagle Mountain as
a community? And we see this is actually quite low
here. But let's remember that 50% of the
respondents had lived here less than 5 years or less. Well,
there's not much time for people to get a strong sense of community
like some of our very well-established communities that are also in the survey
set this year. But it does give you some benchmarks
of places you can go, and I have some data that I think will give
you some, perhaps some pointers. We can see that community
connection is very important here. We see a strong, pretty strong
correlation with overall well-being. We see it with mental health.
So, the stronger that sense of community connection, it does have
a benefit in some of these other areas of life.
There's a couple of things going on in terms of personal demographics and well-being.
Those with disabilities have lower well-being scores.
Those who are homeowners have a higher well-being score.
And we do see a bit of that correlation with income. We see
it very strongly across the data across the state. It is certainly a
signature there in your data, but perhaps not as strong as others.
Also, the community connection, those who are
not Hispanic or Latino seem to have a lower
sense of community connection here. That is really quite— yes,
the Hispanic and Latino community has a higher sense of community connection, and that is
the reverse of most of the communities in the survey.
We also see by age, you can see those age groups
in the from 50, 40 to 50 are actually feeling
more community connected than those who are 18 to 39
or those who are 60 years and over.
Now here's one of the things we're finding quite interesting is well a
Eagle Mountain residents are really very active. They're walking,
they're biking, they're recreating in parks, they're gardening.
They are using trails in and around your city, and everywhere you
see a star, a big star there for community events,
those who attend community events have a statistically
significantly higher level of community connection. So those community
events pay off for those who participate. And then all those smaller
stars, those are still correlated, not quite as strongly as that one with
community connection, but lots of correlations there with well-being
and with community connection. And really, these things appear
to be— the data are showing us that these appear to be worth the investment.
Working on your parks, working on your trails, having these community events, having rec programs,
those who participate seem to have these higher levels of connection and
well-being. Okay, here's a striking one. Folks in Eagle
Mountain feel that the current rate of population growth is too fast.
It is not unlike some of the neighbors around here.
So Saratoga Springs bumps you out just by a little bit,
but yeah, y'all know about your 100% population
growth rate, I'm sure. That percentage
that's saying too fast has gone up in the 6 years since we did this
survey previously, and those that thought it was just right, well, that's plummeted.
So they've replaced, they've switched from just right to too
fast. Economic development, you can
see here, is a lot more mixed.
We've got 50% of folks saying it's actually too
slow, but we still have some saying just right or too fast.
The too slow folks, about the same. They are exactly the same.
The just right folks have declined a little bit, whereas the too fast
folks have come up. So really a mixed kind of response
here. One of the things we look at is cost of living
this year. For those for whom childcare is relevant,
and that looks to be about 46% of the survey takers,
that 74% of them are saying that that is difficult or very
difficult to afford. That one's jumping out in many cities and towns.
But healthcare and housing are also right up there at nearly half of respondents
are saying those are pretty hard to afford. And you still have just
under a third or about a third saying that even food, utilities,
and transportation is is a challenge. So cost of living,
not unique to Eagle Mountain, but something that's going on. Barriers to travel,
travel time, lack of routes and cost are really quite
high here compared to most cities, even in the Wasatch Front.
So you're standing out there a bit. We ask about a lot
of different concerns. This list has grown a fair bit since you participated
in 2020. You've got traffic at the top of
your list. And water supply and water quality there.
And so that's not uncommon to be on the top,
but your percentages are really quite high. You've got a whole smattering
of other things that are above 50% of folks have a moderate
or major concern on these items. I just want to take one minor aside
and say that my other hat is I am the Associate Director of the Utah
Water Research Laboratory up at Utah State. Water is
everything we do. We provide a great deal of services across the
suite of water flows and supply through to water quality
and help with wastewater treatment plants. If you folks
in engineering and in public works have any interest in chatting with us
about how we can support you in the water realms, especially given
how concerned your residents are, we would be really happy to have that
conversation. We would welcome that. Just 2 more
slides. What do people value about Eagle Mountain? They really value— some
of them clearly have a sense of community, feeling of community,
people are friendly. They value the space out here,
the quieter pace of life, and the family-oriented environment.
They do feel there's some sense of peace here, at least somebody did,
and that those trails, that sense of
connection to nature is a valued out here.
What would improve well-being? Focusing on more roads
and infrastructure to accommodate the growth. Another road in and out
they would certainly think would benefit them.
There's some— many seeking a better balance between
growth and homes. We see that in many
of these rapid growth communities. A rec center for especially
folks on the On the young age and the older age is something that
we were hearing a lot in the open comments,
access to recreation areas and making sure people
know about those areas. And with that, I want to say thank you so
much for being a partner. And if I can answer any quick questions, I would
be happy to. I will also add quickly that
I have also shared all of your open comments, and there are
many of them. I think about 80% of the respondents
They've got a lot on their mind. So you have those at your disposal.
We do not share those publicly. We just share them with you.
We use a couple here and there as part of research, but the
bulk of them are yours. So one quick question. How statistically
significant do you think the survey is? Well, because we
allow any resident age 18 or older to participate, it is
not based on a probability sampling. But we know
that based on your adult population and the responses that we have here, you're looking
at about a margin of error of about 5%. But we cannot
say that it is scientifically significantly
representative. However, the demographic correlations that
we saw suggest that— and the numbers of respondents that you have—
say that I would take these results quite seriously.
I can't— because of the sampling lack of— This representative
sampling, I'm not going to go all the way to the bank, but I'm going
to say you've got some pretty good data here compared to many cities.
I was just going to say thank you for that presentation. As I was going
through it, I was like, yep, yep, yep. Like a lot of things make sense
around traffic and connections and parks and all of
that. What— you do this for many other
cities. What were the, like, the Number 1, number 2 things that
would come to the top of your list that you'd recommend our council look at?
Well, I think working on that community connection score, I think,
would be a top item. And that can vary for different folks, what would
make them feel more connected. We could probably dig in here to
your demographics a little bit more and give you more precision on
that if you're interested in that. We would be glad to follow up.
The community connection can be done through community events,
but it can also be gathering places where people
can just get to know each other a little bit better. And those can be
at the neighborhood scale. They don't necessarily have to be all the way up here
at your 30-plus thousand people's, you know,
whole community. Sometimes blooming where people are
planted can be a valuable way to foster those community connections.
I'd say that would be number one. Number one that jumps out,
addressing the concerns of residents on things like water,
things like open space. There may be a lot of other things you're doing
already. The survey results can be a point of communication
and conversation. We hear you. We hear you're concerned about
this, and this is what our city's doing. And that can really be kind of
a magic moment where this you can respond to the data.
We provided flyers for you to.
Okay, thank you. We appreciate your stuff, and, uh, we'll be able
to use that information to help make things better. Did you have anything else
to add, Abby? No, I think a lot of it is really
great though to use for planning and things like that, knowing that they want more
retail and more community events. I really like that, so I appreciate them doing the
survey for us. Thank you. Thanks, thanks for the opportunity to drive down.
Yep, appreciate it. The traffic's terrible leaving town, so good
luck. We'll get some snacks. Yeah,
so with that, we also had our community survey,
the annual community survey, and I think we're
gonna run right into that with Evan. Did you have— okay,
yeah, go ahead.
Sorry. Go ahead. Didn't mean to interrupt you. Good afternoon, Mayor and Council.
I'm pleased to introduce Ron Gailey. He is from OnPoint Insights.
We have worked with their company a number of times before on previous surveys,
including our general plan survey, previous annual surveys.
Today he is here to talk with you all about our
annual survey. We do have a basic
framework for that that we like to use year after year so that
we have comparative results over time. But he is here because there is some
wiggle room where we can make sure that we're getting the answers to
questions that you have from our community at this point in time. So I'll
go ahead and let him take the floor.
Hello everyone, and I'm going to share my screen really
briefly with you.
Okay. On the annual survey, one of the benefits
of the survey that we do do is it allows you to see,
as we saw with the other one, what's important and how you're performing. But we
do it across a great many attributes.
This particular page is showing you from 2024 the
top 20 attributes of about 50 of
what people thought was most important. and then how you're
performing on it. And I only wanted to show you this just
to let you see where things were 2 years ago about what
is important and how you're performing. I've been working with Evan,
and we've been working together to make
a few minor tweaks to the main part of the survey.
It's very solid. I think it's very consistent with the past,
but some things I think are being strengthened. Thank you. or broken out when something
was important and we couldn't tell specifically what was inside.
We're doing that, I think, better for you this year.
We're reducing the number of questions about streets and
roads so that you don't,
like, double count and so forth, right? It'll be a little cleaner
on streets and roads.
But then what I wanted to ask you today As
we're wrapping up the survey and getting ready to go live, is if
there are additional topics you feel we really
ought to explore so that— we
have always in our survey about 3 minutes of questions that we can go deeper
on and ask some additional questions.
And I just wanted to talk with you about maybe some of the things that
may be of interest to you. In the past,
we've done questions about communications.
Now, you know, we had talked about doing more
on parks and recreation, but that's kind of— we held
off on that after my last presentation to you.
But just wanted to find out if there is something where
you'd like to go a little bit deeper this year and explore something
that might help you as you plan for your General plan, or as
you plan for your budgeting.
I would be curious to know, and I'm going to get the council's opinion on
this as well, but I'd be curious to know what would the what the residents
would feel and how and how they would rank like an
ice skating rink versus a field house versus other rec options,
and where they would want us to put our energy. It's a really smart way,
and oftentimes we'll give them a list of about five or six items and have
them prioritize them. I would love to see that. I would be really curious to
see that data. Is there a way when you ask that question to
help them understand the financial impact on them?
Because I think everybody wants something until they realize what the price
tag is. There is a way to do that. And it's a smart
thing to do. As a matter of fact, if you have narrowed it down to
1 or 2 or 3 things maybe, and we
can put the financial implications of that, we can do that.
In some cities, we'll ask them something like, if we were to do,
let's say, a skating rink. If we were to do a skating
rink, should we go big, go good,
or go fair? You know, you do that, and most people say
go big or go fair. Very few say go adequate.
Then you say, well, go big means this financially,
probably, and go go good means this,
probably financially, and go fair means this. What do you
think now? And they'll tell you. And normally with that, you can find out
if you got a go for it or a don't go for it kind of
a response. We've done that for Maple— Mapleton. We've done
it for several cities, as a matter of fact. One of the other things that
has come up over the course of this year is trying to better understand
how our residents need us to communicate
with them, what mode of communication. And I know that
we're attempting to do quite a bit of a
spectrum of communication, but it would be great to get a
better handle on what people are hoping for. So whether
that's mailed postcards, emails,
right, you know, all the different things. We've done that for many cities that have
a great structure for And we can just make sure that it's dialed in for
your specific options here that are under consideration.
The other one that came up previously, and I still think I'm a strong advocate
for getting the answer for, is which recreation programs
our residents want to see us work on next. 'Cause we've got a
little smattering of everything, and we've just brought— we're bringing soccer in-house
for this fall. But I would like to know what's
the next one we should be studying, where we should be putting our efforts into.
So— Do you know, I like that question. It's a little bit long, you know,
because there are several options. And I would suggest that be added
to another survey.
We— it normally takes to do that question, it normally takes about 6
or 7 minutes to kind of go through and find out, like,
For the different age groups, like which of these ideas for
recreation they would most like to do. We can
potentially shorten it and we can potentially make it fit,
but that one is a little bit more time-consuming to get it right.
I— do you think that we could gather adequate
data just to give us a general direction in which
to head? Because— Probably not all of them. Right. All of these
that you're talking about, like one— I mean, it's a little more—
the communication one, that's like 2 minutes. So that's OK.
But this one's probably about a 4 to 5 minute, even if we try to
do it adequate. Because I don't— well, of course, I don't
know what all the programs are in your facility. I think that's what I'm getting
at is if it was just our like first shot
across the bow to figure out like which direction we should
at least start getting information, Doesn't have to be so extensive
in the very first thing? It doesn't. I can show you one we did.
So I can show you one and why what I'm envisioning takes more time.
I can show you one that we did for a city. And we did one
for Tremonton, Utah, but we did one for Melissa, Texas that I'd like to show
you. Both are good. And they each
took like 4 to 5 minutes to do well. But we could
do a shorter version, which I'm going to show you the Melissa, Texas one because
it is short, the one question, but it doesn't go into depth
into what goes within it. So I'm going to just open up my screen here.
Can I— I got one question on that screen real quick. Sorry. Uh-huh.
Just because I want to know the nature of the question.
We can wait. It was towards
the bottom. I can come back to it though.
Oh, hey, I'll come back to that.
Okay, here you're saying where we were, right?
Okay, so right here, uh, the question or the—
sorry, it's right there. It says, uh, city's own police force.
It had 9% as far as important, uh,
7% were very good, but then the very poor was 67%.
What was the nature of that question? Does the 67 represent
that people don't like the Sheriff's Office or that they
prefer their own? You see what I'm saying? I think this question, you didn't
have one, right? And we put it in there, how is the city doing with
the police force? And I think it came off negative.
And, but we didn't explain it
or go into detail of what that would involve or what was, you know,
or how it is. I think this is just a general
rating of the police force at the time. So is it fair to say that
that's really not a very good representation of what's really—
because of the nature of the question? I think it is, because, yeah, I think
in general we're just asking them to rate the police force. I don't know if
they're rating traffic. I don't know if they're rating patrolling
the neighborhoods. There are a lot of things we don't know about that particular question
because we didn't go into depth. I think the word own is what's throwing me
off. That's why I'm— that's where I was at too. Right? That's a
nuanced word to throw in there. So that's why when you say own,
then what's the results? And then if it's not important, meaning 9%,
but yet it's 67% poor. Well, then also because if we go to the police
department, which we did rate,
right? And you see the 5th one down?
a fair number of people have had interaction with the police, and if they
did, the results are pretty solid. Yeah, and that's why I said
the nature of the question. And maybe the answer, because I
have to agree, that one was like, they're not rating something that you have,
they're rating something that you don't have. I think it's the nuance between whether we
have our own police force or whether we have a sheriff's contract. Right, it should
have been a separate question. That's where it gets skewed. Could we just talk about
maybe police presence instead of calling it police?
I think, I think that's fair, and,
and I do think that is a fair question and an excellent one, Mayor,
to bring up. And I think the, the follow-up question
after that would be like, do you feel safe?
Like, because I think those are like, do you see our police here and
do you feel safe? Those are like, I think— In most cities, that's the way
we have done it, is where you just talk about Neighborhood patrols,
and you find out that, and then overall, how are they doing? But so I
don't see that you have a police problem, and maybe they don't like the idea
of making your own. But 2% of our people love the court we
have. But I
would say that this was not the perfect question,
Mayor. Now I am going
to go to Melissa, Texas, and show you one question. So the question So
the way we did this is we said— here
it is. As the city begins to budget for the next
fiscal year, the city needs input on what recreational classes,
events, and programs are of most interest for our residents.
Our city may or may not be able to meet everyone's wants or desires,
but it's helpful to know what's valuable. And then we showed them the list
that you see here, which is rather broad. So there's fitness programs,
sports programs, outdoor nature programs. They just had a variety.
They had so many things they were considering doing. They had about 60 or so
ideas of things that they could do.
And this gave them a broad overview of the types of things that came out
highest. Is that the direction you're thinking?
I think for us, I mean, for me, when I ask, We just barely
brought soccer in-house, and outside of junior jazz, there's not a lot of
other things that we are providing. We partner with outside
organizations to bring those services here. I would
like to know which sports type thing is the next specific
thing recreation-wise that they want us to do, because we have lots of really
great opportunities within our community from private entities for fitness
and and some of those other things. At least there's something, but there's not
private entities per se that are offering really good versions of
recreational sports. So for me, it's more of a, which is the next sports
thing you want us to take on? So when we did it
for this city, after we asked about a lot of attributes,
it narrowed down to these are the top 20 that people were
most interested in seeing. And I don't know if you can see this well,
but they just had a variety of things that they would love the city to
focus on. But this did allow them to focus on the few that
they wanted. And maybe we show you this list and you choose
from the list of what we were considering in another city,
and we narrow it down and have a smaller list that would be in your
consideration set here. And then we just present the things that you're
considering.
Okay. Anything else on that one? Was that the end of the
results? I want to make sure. Is there more slides? No more slides that we
need to show. And really, we were just
trying to get feedback for anything new that you wanted. And this was super
helpful. And a thing to clean up.
Which I think is also helpful too. So we'll do that with the police.
When you say own the police, I mean, that's obviously a nuance that could,
for people who know, you know, throw the question a different direction.
I think it should have been a question of its own. Should we own our
own police, yes or no, or something like that? But it shouldn't have been the
rating in general. Yeah. The rec stuff,
and you added something, right? You happy with the
way it looks? We did rec communications and then we just said major
investments into something like ice skating. Yeah, the nature of communications, that's a big problem
we've had and maybe we talk about the way that question is worded, but it's—
the public has had a big push this year
about transparency. It's not a matter of being transparent, it's a matter of— Getting
the information out. Yeah, even if we said it, they didn't hear it or didn't
get to them. We need to figure out a way to
better get the word out to people
so that they have it available and in front of them. So that's something.
Did you want to add one more thing, Melissa? Yeah.
Oh gosh, I completely— oh, I was wondering if it would be instructive,
because I think we've had 3 different iterations of our Citizens
Academy. What if there was just one question with the demographic
stuff was like, have you participated in the Eagle Mountain Citizens Academy?
Because I think those people tend to have a better understanding of what's going on
and make very informed decisions. And I think it'd be kind of fun to see,
are they a statistical outlier or like that? So it's
almost a demographic, right? That's what I'm getting at. A demographic of the handful.
How many have been through it?
Probably 60.
Yeah, because it's 60 people. Do you know what? I just don't think it makes
sense to use that as a demographic. If you— I mean, you have what,
60,000 people here? We're going to go to 1,000 people. 80,000.
Oh my heavens. And then we're hoping to find those 60 people out of the
group, and it's probably very unlikely we would get 5. Okay.
A lot of the people that have been end up coming to the meetings.
Yeah, for sure. Look, I'm in favor, but— and you may want to find out
people who'd be interested in going through as the Citizen Academy. We could ask people
if they'd like to do that. And then you could just, you know, you could
get a nice list of, you know, if so, you know,
give us your contact information and you could invite people who are very interested
in that. You guys, do we want to know— I know we talked about
recreation and communication. Do we want to talk about what resources we as
a city or private entities have brought into
our community? Like, The fact that Department of Workforce Services is coming,
food pantries, some of those things like are— because
we always kind of guess and throw a dart at the dartboard when it comes
to Community Development Block Grant funds, and I'm just wondering if that would
be a useful question.
What's the question? Whether or not— which
services our residents want us to be providing. Post office.
Well, yeah. Yeah. I got that question today. Bus routes. Yeah.
Yeah. Okay. All right. So we already
know that. Yeah, I think it's a little bit too broad. It would just
have to be, is there something missing? And then we just have to take the
feedback. Right. Right.
Any other comments? Off topic, I was gonna say that I did watch some
of the podcasts. Evan did great. Oh my heavens, yeah. Your team was good
in it. And then I watched some from like Colorado and some of your other
stuff. It was pretty fun. Do you know what? It was really something to see
all of the— that was a big topic and it's
getting bigger all the time. Yep, it was fun. So good job. Appreciate your team
and what they do for us. Thank you. Good, thank you.
All right, we're gonna move on back to the top. Item 1A, the Eagle Square
commercial signs. And Steven is up front today with
that one. All right. Thank you.
Lacey, can I have the screen, please? Sorry.
As it's coming up, so as an introduction,
as you know, the Seagull Square commercial, I don't know if the
last time it's come to City Council when it was approved, it's probably been a
year or more. It's been platted. If you've
driven past it, they've been grading the site, working on it.
We have received an application to put 2 signs
up for the development. So one of them would be here on their—
I guess it'd be in the lot, but along that private road.
There's no really issues with that one. The one that's coming before you that we
want direction on is the one here along Pony Express. So it's the sign
S1. And the reason mostly
to get feedback is, is it is in the city's right-of-way.
So typically that's— we don't allow any structures in the
city's property, especially in the right-of-way. Yes,
there's potentially to allow it if that's the city council's desire,
whether that's through a lease or how that you want to figure that out.
But before we move this sign application forward, we just want that direction and direction
for the applicant how they should proceed.
Yeah, I think if there's no utilities or issues there, I mean,
it, it doesn't look like it's in the way as
long as it's not blocking visual traffic or creating any safety issues.
Do you have any concerns with safety? If we were to widen the
road down the road, um, do we have an idea of what
kind of cost we would be saddling a future council and
taxpayers with? Would it just be essentially building a new one?
Well, that's a risk for them, right? But I don't think the city would be
bearing the cost of moving that sign. If we widen the road and we take
out their sign because we— sorry, it wasn't— um, if we
widen the road and it's our project
and we remove their sign because we're going to put road there,
don't we have an obligation to relocate that sign?
Typically, no. Like, in the case of a,
you know, using a good example would be a franchise agreement with a telecom
or cable company. We may, if it's for a city project,
we make them move their stuff at their expense. I don't know why we would
treat this any differently than Comcast or DirectCom.
Does it— can it produce any issues in the PUE? That's one
of the things I'm worried about is you have other
infrastructure that may need to go in there.
It's just one of the concerns that I have. If you want to run some
power or some water or some other supply down the side of the road,
what do we do in that instance? I will say that there's already some
city signs that are along that area
that have advertisements on them. And I felt like the contractor
that was putting it in was able to navigate bringing the utilities
and things that they needed to underneath and around the signs as they
are there right now. So I think it's probably doable,
but maybe engineering would have a better idea for us.
Yeah, Vince, I've heard a few questions— site triangles, things like that. I know David's
not here for the specific stuff, and then the utilities. You want to weigh in
Before we go. Yeah, we, we did take a look
at this and we, we worked with the applicant to make sure that
this sign was pushed back far enough so that even with future expansion of
this roadway, it wouldn't have to be moved again. We didn't
want to put it in a place where it works now and didn't work for
the future. And so yeah, we did look at that. We did have them push
it back a little bit so it's outside of that future right-of-way.
So as far as sight triangles, yeah, it's far enough back that it won't affect
the sight triangle coming out of that intersection. Even with expansion?
Even with expansion. Do we have any examples of where we
have signage right now that's in the current right-of-way that we should— that we could
be aware of that would look like this or that might be impacted
like this? It's my
understanding that every sign— so
here on the intersection of Ranches and Pony,
um, there's a sign here for this office
building. The Chevron has a sign. Um, both of those
are within the right-of-way as well.
So there is some, at least some historical context
that we have done this in the past for some of the businesses, recognizing that
it's a risk for the business and that at some point when that road— not
if that road widens, when that road widens. And I mean,
we're seeking funding for that now. So my hope
is, is that we're tearing this sign down in the next year or 2.
I, for your sake, Mr. Simpson, I hope that's
not the case, but, but I just think that's a
risk that the development or developer has to be willing to take if we're,
if we're willing to say, go ahead and build it in the right-of-way, recognizing that
there's a risk it may need to come down.
Isn't this what David's working on with you, Mayor, at MAG, to try and get
the 7 lanes? Yeah, and I was just, I was kind of going to go
into that. I was with MAG today most of the morning, and, uh,
so as far as the TIP funds We were working on the RTP today,
but TIP funding we just finished,
and then the next one will be 2 years, and of course 3
years after that before we get it. So it would be 5 years before we
get it. Now, would we pre-fund that? Likely. But at minimum,
it's not approved yet, but it would be.
So not in the next— it would be approved in 2 years,
then we'll Maybe 3.
Yeah, so we'd build it in 3 to 4.
But that's the risk. And happy to allow the applicant to weigh
in as well if there was any other questions too.
Is there questions for the applicant?
I do. So, I mean, so Mr. Simpson, obviously you're making the request, so this
must be at least something that you're willing to, to, to take
that risk Yes. Yeah, Councilman Wright, you're correct on
that. We had worked with the engineering department there,
and the recommendation for the future
widening of Pony was to go back 25
feet from top back of curb. And so this sign begins 30 feet
from top back of curb, and then to clear the
safety issues, We're 80 feet from Porter's Crossing,
so we go east 80 feet to make sure those sight angles
are there. And so we're trying to make it similar
to our sister development to the west,
Porter's Crossing, where Ridley's is. That particular sign is
entirely in the city easement, and so
when you widen that street, we'll— we're going to
have to move that sign. back. That one's entirely there, done back I
think in 2013. That's exactly— yeah, we appreciate the
consideration and, uh, to let us put this one, uh,
in, in the right-of-way following the recommendations
from the city engineer and the planners.
So anybody going to struggle with that?
No, it sounds like staff worked with the applicant to really get it where it
needs to be, so I don't have any objections. So probably the direction, Mayor,
is to just bring it back and let us do it, let us deal with
it as an action item, right? Okay. Okay.
Is that fair enough? Sounds good. So do you
want the agreement drawn up then and brought back to you? Yeah, and I think
the direction is obviously the owner's risk, right? That would be the
key factor. Other than that, I didn't hear any other
major concerns, right? So if you're okay with that,
then I think that's what we'll do. Okay,
perfect. Okay, any other comments or questions? No, just that I need
an encroachment letter from Vince for the sign too. That's a public utility
easement. It's not in the city right-of-way, but it is a PUE. And so
I have my encroachment letters from all the other utilities,
but Eagle Mountain needs to provide one. So yeah,
for us to If that gets drafted, either one. And Vince
has got an email on that. Drafted and reviewed by Marcus, and then,
uh, then we can do it as an action item to approve
the, the contract, if you will. Okay.
The letter, however Marcus directs us.
So is that all right? Thank you. Okay.
Yep. Thank you. And Stephen will help that process move along, so.
All right. Moving right along. I appreciate everybody being ready
today. So, 1B, the home business standards.
And I think this one's Brandon.
I put it on the agenda, but this is just—
I put this on here for the council to have a discussion about the
home business standards. You know, they're in Title 17.
Chapter 65. I think there was some question
about whether the council should— I think
they just want to— the idea is to have a discussion about whether some
of the home business requirements should be adjusted to allow—
I know one type of use was maybe for agriculture or farm-related
uses. So I think Councilor Clark has a little bit more information.
For you, I do. I've had at least four different
residents reach out to me as a council member to talk to me about some
of this. There are some that have open application with
business licensing, and our home business license, the way it's
set up right now, is the only thing this particular business can get licensed
as is like a greenhouse home-based business.
And based off of what I've heard and read.
That our city attorney has said is if it's, um,
a greenhouse one, then the only thing that they can sell is greenhouse products,
which they deemed was plant starts, microgreens,
plants, and potentially even broadening it wide enough to include
bees and bee-related items, right?
Um, but one of the things that they would like to do is
to sell more than just produce and plants,
but to be able to sell like eggs from their chicken coop
and other farm-related items. So I think that
this code could be updated as simply as changing
it from greenhouse products to farm products and then provide
some definition of that. Um, if we did
that and they just complied with the rest of the home business licensing
requirements like trip count and some of those other things That I
think would take care of it. Steven, I know that
you've— did you talk to the applicant at all
that had the open application? Have they reached out to you specifically,
or they've just been working with Jonna? I've talked to them.
Okay. Is there anything specifically about, or? I'm just
wondering if there's anything else that we need to discuss
as a body to determine whether or not we want to make this change.
Change. So it broadens it to kind of support those agricultural
uses. Yeah, I mean, I think,
like Councilmember Clark mentioned, I don't think our code meets what she needs to
do now. Um, opening up to whether
it's animal products, animal byproducts, that, that's,
yeah, a different conversation. That would probably encompass more of what she's looking for.
Um, honey was one that Our code doesn't explicitly allow right now to be
able to sell out of the house. So it's really—
we could go a lot of different places, but for this one specifically, that would
help. One other thing, just to piggyback— sorry, Councilmember Whiting,
I jumped the gun on you. Um, baked products
is also something that we're seeing a lot and lot— a lot more of
our residents doing, and they'll advertise it and say, I've made 8 loaves of sourdough,
you can come pay for them and Venmo me and pick them up on my
porch. They're just front porch bakeries in effect, and they're not getting
tons and tons of traffic, but it is a way for our residents
to be able to stretch their income and, and support themselves a little
bit more and be a little bit more self-sufficient. So that's one other item that
kind of came up in that discussion. I was just going to say I 100%
support this. This is, this is to me part of the culture of Eagle Mountain,
and we need to have this.
I don't disagree with that, Councilmember Whiting, but I guess I do have some
concerns. Is there a line that
needs to be drawn? That's really the question that I'm asking, because are we
going to allow the slaughter of cows and the resale of beef?
I just think that this is something that probably requires a little more forethought
and some discussion. What about chickens? You know,
Do you want to buy some chicken breasts from me? Because I might raise some
chickens and bring them, make them available for purchase.
So I just think that those are some of the discussions that perhaps we should
have. I think we should look at loosening it up a little bit. I'm not
arguing a counterpoint. I just think that, I think
there has to be some guidelines and some boundaries that we set.
I think To Councilmember Wright's point, there are quite
a few regulations, both federal, state, county health
department, that would govern some of those additional things.
But things that are like, uh, the bread, the eggs,
the honey, right now our code— Milk. Milk,
uh, milk is governed by a state code with raw milk stuff, and so is
meat, to be honest with you. Um, and that has to be done at like
a USDA butcher, all of those things. But I think,
um, we could broaden it to farm products
and then dig into some of the concerns,
um, concern areas that you're talking about. Because I do know that
there are people within our community that do sell meat that
they've raised, but they bring the meat, the animal, to a butcher,
then bring the butchered meat home and sell it for
pickup and different things for people to purchase. So I think in a
lot of ways it's already happening. But in this particular instance,
they went through the motions of getting a business license and
it helped us discover a hole in our business license code.
I think to me the scope probably needs to be narrow,
one by one, not a categorically hear all the
things so we can have more thoughtful discussion around eggs, how many eggs,
and what falls within this, within the state code.
I know there are businesses that are operating outside
of our code today, like RV parking is a big one, that we should probably
have a bigger conversation about that as well. But yeah,
I don't, I don't have an issue, but I think we probably want to keep
the scope narrow and within the confines of the state law and federal law.
Do you think that our restrictions of how many trips per
day, how many employees they can have on site for a home-based business,
are restricting enough, narrowing enough
to be able to get it to where it needs to be instead of deciding
how many eggs or how much meat or some of those other things? Because I
think the trips is a natural limitation that's built into
our code already. Yeah.
So, well, and I think, uh, off-street parking
has to be part of that so they're not plugging up streets. Trips per days,
uh, if those things are all addressed
in the home-based business already, that's a start, right?
So is that the main concerns? Not so much what's
for sale, it's, uh, more about trips, parking,
Any other major— I think the goal
is to have some kind of— if you want to start a business, you're likely
going to do it out of your garage. That's the whole point. But it gets
to a point where you need to go buy land and
go big. And it's figuring out what's that transition from being a home-based
business to taking advantage of the residential
discount on your property tax. What I'm wondering— so I was thinking about
this a minute ago, but You reminded me, like, say you're going to sell meat
or slaughter chickens, right? Something that we just got brought up. Do we
do that on a quarter-acre lot, or does it have to meet the animal
code table, if you will? You know, you can't have
beef until you have— is it half acre or 1
acre, depending on what the— Does
the beef have to be raised on your lot, or could you have
an ag lot somewhere else that you're raising ranching the beef
on and then butchering it. Well, that's, that's what I was thinking through.
Can you tie it to that table to avoid— I mean, if you're on a
5th of an acre and you're selling, commercially selling beef
that is generating 25 trips, you're also turning
your place into a refrigerated— your house just became a
meat locker, right? You couldn't do it on a lot that small,
so you're going to need a storage shed or something outside of that. That's kind
of why I thought Can you correlate it with the lot size in
the animal code? It doesn't necessarily have to be raised there, but to sell
slaughtered chickens and beef, you know, maybe you need more room.
I think the home-based business code does set some guidelines
and it sets some guardrails there, you know, with the
trips per day, the number of employees. And I think it's really just
differentiating between a commercial business and
a home-based business. And, and if we can do that, I don't
think we should be regulating things so that somebody that wants to keep bees
can't sell the honey. That's ridiculous to me.
And if our code doesn't allow for that, we need to fix it. And I
think that's what Melissa is talking about. But by the
same token, I don't think that we should be creating commercial chicken egg
production farms in our Townhome condominiums,
right? I just— so I think that we have to just balance it. And I
do think that the animal code will play a big part in that. And I
think the home-based business already does some of that.
Yeah, that's where I was saying, if you can get the home-based business, the animal
code to kind of dictate some of the uses or something. So then
if that's going to come back, obviously, Brandon, you'll assign that to
whoever's going to work on that code. Do you feel like there's Clear
direction on the guardrails. Yeah, I think we've got enough information.
Yep, sorry, thank you. I think we have enough information to move
forward on this one. Is there anything else that we need to do?
Okay, I think that's perfect. We appreciate that.
Was that good? All right, um, all right,
item 1C. I think this is our last of our discussion items. This is
the community garden presentation. I know there's a slew of people
here that are going to work on this, but Steve, did you have an introduction
or do you want to turn it over to the community board?
The Community Services Board has been discussing this, and especially at
their last meeting, and we invited Jen Corrington from,
from the community who's heavily involved
and puts together the farmers market. Yeah,
and I know Brad's also had some, uh,
insight here, so go ahead.
Hello, Mayor and Council. Oh no, it's not
going. Okay, so I am
here to present a community garden pilot program.
What we're— all we're asking for tonight is if you support the
idea of it, if the site that we have proposed is acceptable,
and if we should keep going forward with the idea.
The reason we want to do a community garden or have this is because there's
a lot of residents without yard space. And it
would be a way to learn and teach skills
of self-reliance and create community connection, and it could be scalable
if it— if this one works. This is
the proposed site, so it's over not far from here, just west of
Pioneer Park. West? Yeah.
And this is close up. This is what it looks like. I'm not sure exactly
where in this Rectangle, it would be, but it's
somewhere in this rectangle.
And that's my understanding of it, at least. We would just need to have that
confirmed. How it would work is
we'd have five to ten raised beds approximately, and we
would need they would have improved soil and drip irrigation. We would have a
coordinator, which is why we've invited Jen here, which she
has a lot of. Experience and expertise, and she
would be able to run the program for us. And ideally, we would have zero
requirements from the city. We wouldn't need any hours
from you guys, except for maybe a few confirmation things and
things we can't get around.
The idea— this is a model that we looked at—
was the Wasatch Community Gardens, which They have assigned plots to
each to specific residents, and they have an
each bed has a named steward. They have a remedy period,
so if someone stops maintaining their plot, they have to fix it within
a certain amount of time, and then they have a requirement for
volunteer hours for the gardener.
We what we had talked about was having a small,
modest annual plot fee and a minimal monthly maintenance fee that could
go towards things like, um, what did we say?
Seeds. Oh, seeds and the, the water and
fertilizer and things like that. Um, and then we'd have raised
beds with imported soil, which avoids— I mean, we have rough
soil here. It's hard, can be hard to grow things. So we would have some
soil brought in, and then we would just have oversight by
a subcommittee on the Community Services Board, and then that
would be— that subcommittee would be mostly
manned by someone like Jen if that were to be who was voted in.
Having a drip line makes it so
that we wouldn't be wasting any water. The water's already there,
and we wouldn't need to have any— I
mean, we would still need to have a hose With a little bit, we'd have
to have water to be able to put in the new plants, but it would
all be maintained by a drip line.
And then this was just potential, a range of costs
of what it might cost to start up. There are things that we have
added in later phases, like having a fence and a shed,
that could be done sooner or later, depending on what you guys
thought about. And then
the timeline would— we would just need your direction now, and then in
the fall is when we would like to prepare the site and have it all
ready to go by spring.
And so that's what we would need. And do you guys have any questions?
So that's where the disc golf course is, right? And so
how And so I guess
one of the questions you had is, is this going to take what could have
otherwise been parking? Yes, that is one of the things on there. Some people had
requested— they had made a request saying that they
would like parking there, and that would be a good spot for it.
But there is a water line there today. Yes. In that parking area?
Mm-hmm. So we've got irrigation running through there, is that
right? Yeah, as we mentioned earlier,
I think in a previous meeting when we discussed this, there is a meter
that's already been set there with a backflow prevention device.
In the past, we have had community gardens tried
to be facilitated there twice that I know of, and we did
the same thing. Where the city basically covered the cost of the seed and
most of it was native type vegetation
that would be grown and edible. And so, but we
just never could get it to take off. And I think the city ended up
spending about $10,000 through about 2 efforts and we never seen a
byproduct from it. So that's the history of it.
But as Jessie reached out, my conversation
with her was, If we're gonna go back and we're gonna pilot a site,
I think that we should try the same location and just see if we
can figure out and get something moving, and then you can figure out how to
modify from that point. And so that was my recommendation.
And that way we're not losing as much if it does for some reason fail.
But as us and the Community Services Board, as we discussed
with Jen, I think that having her as the
coordinator for this will make it a win.
Yes, you can make a comment. Thanks so much.
Um, I— we've had a lot of people reach out from the community that
are very, very interested in doing this. We had one guy that came and talked
for about 45 minutes to us at the farmer's market about it, really interested.
Older retired people sometimes, and there's so many people who
want to know how to garden. but don't know how.
And especially with our economy, I think that it is an important
thing that we try and feed our community. So even
though I would be over it, I would recruit
other people. And I think that is going to make the difference of whether
it succeeds or fails, is if we have people who are
really interested in doing it, who have the time, who want to donate that,
and actually make it happen. And I think it also needs
to be food plants, things that they will actually
eat, rather than just something that is native that's
edible. I think if we're, you know, and if we do it
right, the right way, I think that it could be really successful. And it could—
we could possibly have several of these throughout the community. So the
people that are being drawn in into the Can they be from
anywhere in the city, or is this going to be like a zone restricted
only within a certain area? I think— Do you just go out and sign up
for it and go farm? I think anybody in the city. I don't
think it necessarily has to be from that neighborhood. And then if it turns
out good, then we— okay, we put it into another neighborhood.
So part of what— just to clarify what Brad was talking about too
with the physical Financial impact and things like that. My understanding is at this
point, very little to zero staff time and no financial
ask from the community. At this time, that is correct, yes. We're just
looking for direction. Won't it need some to install water,
like to get the spigot part of the water line on and some of those
other things staff-wise? So it's just setup cost
but not maintenance costs, correct? Yes.
Okay. I actually am a huge supporter of this.
There's places all over the state of Utah where Master
Gardeners go and volunteer to Thanksgiving Point, Temple Square.
They go and they help maintain a certain area that they're given
responsibility for, and it's awesome. So like, I think this is the direction
we want to head as a city. Well, and on
this, like, something that I know has been thrown around out there is
different classes, and what better place to have a gardening class and add a garden.
It would give us a place to do that.
Mayor? I just want to add one. I think my biggest
concern with this idea over the years has just been the liability that it
could potentially put the city into. And what I mean by that is we've talked
a lot about in these corridors putting a lot of fruit trees in or doing
these community gardens. And what if somebody goes out and sprays chemical
application on something to treat for some bug that's there and then somebody picks
the fruit and gets sick. And so that's
my protective nature of the city to bring up these things. And I think that
some of those things need to be mitigated as we work through this. And I
think that we need some barriers or parameters to work through it
and address some of those situations if we are gonna move forward with it,
just to protect the city. Like a waiver, I understand
that I could die from eating these peaches. I also think that the fence
probably is, one that should happen sooner
rather than later because— and we get a lock on
the water spigot. And those— somebody
asked the cost of the water. That is part of what that monthly maintenance fee
for whoever is. They would basically rent a space. Like, say for instance,
the box is a 4 by 8. They would rent a 4 by 4 or
a 4 by 8. And so then those monthly costs would help
pay for all of those My only thought is if
we move forward with this, and I'm supportive as well, that we just
have good materials, that we don't halfway do this where
your 2x4s are rotting out in 2 years. I mean, I think this
is a social experiment. They don't own the boxes, they don't
own the material, the equipment. It's not their own property. And when it's
not yours, you tend to just let things dilapidate. I think that's a good point.
So I think if we move forward, that the
materials would need to be good quality, that can be durable,
last a long time, like a playground. You just build it
to last. Well, and I fully support that, and that can get a little more
costly, of course, but that is why, I mean, if the city was
open to it, we could have a sponsor-a-bed program or something like
that where different people or businesses could donate money or They
could donate the bud for us, and that would be
a way to make sure it was done the right way. See, and I like
that idea because it could help people that maybe couldn't afford to pay the maintenance
fee, but they could seek sponsorships. But so what I'm hearing, or what I'm understanding,
and maybe you can correct me, it sounds like there's support,
but we need maybe some— I don't
know if I want to call it a contract. We need some guardrails or some
agreements, if you will, LOI, whatever Mechanism that says
here's the the property, here's who the manager
is at this time, and and here's how it's going to operate. For instance,
the liability question on the sprays that if there's spray used
that number one has to be approved by the city first. You can't spray without,
and then secondly posting a sign or something that says
that this has been sprayed, or you know there's some kind of. Notice, you know,
I'm just giving an example. So go ahead. Yeah,
I'll share some thoughts. I'm probably gonna be the one who's the outsider on
this a little bit. I don't think this is a good idea for the city
to get involved in this. And so my
approach to it would be to look for corporate sponsorship, to find
a way to put it. I think the city could donate the land, or at
least dedicate the land and make the water accessible. But I don't think the city
should take responsibility of managing it, or playing any part of it.
I think if the community wants to see it be successful, that we
should go seek some private funding to put in the original beds, and then
let the city dedicate the space for that to happen, and let those who wanna
come participate pay the few dollars that you're talking about to be able to
do that. And Jen, I don't know where you're gonna find your time. I mean,
I know how busy you are. I'm grateful that you're willing to teach that to
our residents, and I think that it, I think in concept I really
enjoy it. I just don't think it's something the city should be funding and
being held responsible for. So I think that is the thing,
is it's on city land, and that's why I wanted the guardrails. There is no
funds asked and no staff time, but the land is there. So like,
that's why I said I think we need the sign that says that,
you know, it's been sprayed, or— But who's going to take that,
Mayor? I mean, and who's going to monitor it? Are we going to have a
staff member that goes by and watches this every— I mean, those are the problems
that I think these types of things cause, or at
least the concerns from a liability standpoint. I mean, if I'm a private business owner
and you're asking to come do this on my property, I have all the same
concerns that I have as a member of the city council for the city.
I mean, there'd have to be some indemnification from my perspective of
anybody who participates in it or consumes anything that's grown in
it. The city needs some indemnification from my perspective.
There's just too many unknowns in that.
That's problematic for me as someone who looks out for some of
those things in my own private life, in my own business.
The buck always stops with me. If you can find someone
to sponsor, I'll sponsor a bed. I'll just say that out loud and on the
public record. I'll be happy to sponsor a bed at the $200 or whatever
you need, but I think we We can find a way to do that through
our business partners rather than trying to
put that on the city. And only if we can find a path forward with
our attorney to find some way to indemnify the city against some
potential future loss. I would just kind
of ask too, with the concerns about liability, we have park
equipment that people play on and could get hurt at. How do we
indemnify ourselves with that? There's signage, play at your own risk,
those kinds of things. So I feel like the way
that we create some of the guardrails that you're talking about,
because us doing it as a city versus a private business doing
it, there's a lot different liabilities that you
have to take on as a business because the buck stops
with you. But as a city, it's to me it's like. Playground equipment in a
lot of ways. So I just maybe wanted to jump in there really
quickly. Um, as far as things like park equipment
and all that kind of thing, anybody can sue anybody for any reason, and the
city could be sued at any time. And that's why we have insurance with the
trust. We mitigate the impact of that by having policies
and procedures in place, by having good record keeping that says this is
how we're maintaining this, and all that type of I think what I'm hearing from
various groups, there are various members of the council
here, is that the word guardrails or
the world or the rules or how it's going to be administered— did
the city act prudently? Did we put the right rules in place?
Did they sign the right waiver? Have we worded it properly?
Or whatever we needed to do to make sure that we mitigate
the risk if we do move forward with this in this direction. I have seen
this. I have seen it be successful in cities where there are participants
where that really come out. I've seen it die on the vine
more than I've seen it be successful when all of the work falls on one
person. And that's the big fear.
And so it's really when a collective group comes together and you have a large
enough population base that it's being watched, because oftentimes
if it is just a small group. Then you get the vandalism and you get
people coming in. And, and, and then I,
I have 8 kids and we've grown a lot of gardens and we're
really good at putting it in and really bad about,
uh, weeding and maintaining it. And it, by fall, it looks
a lot different than it did in the spring. So.
I, I just want to say that I'm super supportive of this because
I think for years I've been advocating for something like
this. And there's always going to be concerns
about anything we do as a city, but sometimes we need to say,
what is it going to take for us to get to yes? And I think
when residents bring something to us and say, this is what we want, especially when
we're looking at all of the tax things, our budget, all of that stuff,
this is a low-cost way to say to the residents,
We're still trying. We're being penny pinchers about it, but we're still trying to make
sure that you have those quality of life amenities. So like,
I want to help find whatever the rules are, whatever the
signage has to be, so that we can make this wildly successful. Because I love
when people tell us you're not going to be able to do this.
It's my favorite. So— I mean, we have their
community garden boxes in the Section 8 housing.
I'm just curious how they're functioning because those exist and they're
on private ground, HOA ground. So I mean,
I think there are opportunities that exist, Councilmember Clark, and I'm not aware
of them actually functioning in any meaningful way today. Now they
might be, I could be wrong about that, but I know that we
have approved in some developments those things as an amenity, and I'd be curious
to see how they're functioning, if they're functioning at all.
Okay, on the north side of Silver Spur Way,
it looks like the city owns either side of that. And so there's
like a gravel area on the northwest side, looks like it's city-owned, so people
could park there. And then the northeast side, if ever we needed to create a
parking for the— this golf course, it looks like there's room there. So I'm
not worried about the parking aspect and the garden taking that up.
So again, I think the two things that I've heard is number
one, maybe we'd set some land aside. We don't want to touch it outside of
that, and I think that is what they're saying. But then number two is
I think there needs to be some kind of agreement,
if you will, that says how it's going to function.
That's that's what if there's is that what the
council would or wouldn't support? Or is there more or less than that? That's what
I'm trying to get to. Is that— I think the money
is not the issue. We can find sponsors. I think it's
the support piece and whether or not we want to throw our weight behind it
as a city and try it one more time. And maybe the
Community Services Board works with their garden committee to bring us
what those guidelines are to bring, because they have rules that they want
to keep too, because they're going to be putting their time into it. So I
think for me, the next step that I'd like to see is bring us the
next layer of it, and let's see if we can address some of the concerns,
kind of mitigate some of those. So that's, that's what I was getting at,
is it wasn't a money question. They're not asking for any money. The next layer
is some type of LOI, contract,
MOU that says the city gives the land, this is
the manager, and here's what we'll do to You know, as far as signage,
spray, permissions, is that, is that what
we're looking for? Yeah, I think so. And is that something you'd support, or— I
don't want to do it as an exercise. I think anytime someone in our community
stands up and says, I want to lead an initiative to better our community,
our park, or whatever, and no staff is required,
let's do it. I'm in support, but I also think we need
to Be careful around risk, liability, that kind of stuff, which Marcus
is a genius. He'll figure that out. I support
this a lot. I'm really grateful. Our community connection score was low. This will increase
our community connection. I'm willing to give it a try. Let's do it.
So it looks like we've at least got a majority to go to the next
step with the contract. Now, I don't know that that's a staff-driven— I'll take
a little advice from staff, but is that something that we could let the Community
Services Board— I also know that Charlotte's here that worked on this.
Could we assign them to bring us something, or do we want to— Marcus,
you went to— do we want to do that wording ourselves? Was it— is it
something that— I know we're busy. Could they bring us an MOU?
How do you want to see it?
Okay, so I want to make sure I understand where we're at
at this point. So where we would agree
to let them sort of use our land,
lease it, if you will, for a community garden,
they would agree to— so who is the they, I guess, is the real question.
Who's the entity we'd be allowing to come in and do it?
So that's my first question. I think the city's authorizing the land and
whether the management's under the— So is it going to be our community gardens or
somebody else's that they're using our land for? Because I thought
that— That's what the latter was, what we had settled on. But if it's going
to be our program, then,
then I think it's a very different proposition versus somebody else's program
on our land. Well, it's definitely a city-sponsored group that's
bringing this. So yeah, so is that— So if it's going to be our program,
then we would, you know, have people sign a waiver of liability for
using the program. I mean, obviously Yeah.
You know, posting of signs disclaiming liability is helpful,
though not necessarily dispositive on issues of liability.
You know, it's just a matter
of, well, how are we going to manage compliance with the
program? Who's going to do it? Make sure that people are signing the waivers,
because it's one thing to say we're going to require waivers, another thing to follow
up and make sure that everyone who's engaged, who's using the program, whether as a
garden or as a customer of somebody using, you know,
growing something there or whatever, whoever's consuming it is signing a
waiver. I mean, that does sound very, you know, but that would be the way
we'd handle it if it's going to be our program and we just have to
be willing to accept the risk. So what's the tool that we want to use
to govern this? Is it an MOU? Is it a— With whom? It would be
with our community So, I mean, the committee, we wouldn't enter
into— the Community Services Board is not a separate legal entity.
But I think it's— Apart from the city. It's just, so you can't enter an
agreement with yourself. Well, then I wanna make sure that we are able to list
the protocol of how it's managed. So we would adopt the policy.
So do you wanna say— And this is how we wanna manage it. So I
would leave that to the Community Services Board to prepare. So have them bring that
to the policy. And then I'd be happy to review it
if they want me to, and— or if you want me to,
and we'll go from there. But we would want anyone using
the program to sign a waiver of liability, or anyone volunteering.
So let me recap this again, and then I'll make sure we sell this board.
So they will bring us a policy that says this
is how it will function, with this who manages, this who oversees. How will signage,
things like that, whatever we've talked about, we would enact
it as a policy and then that managing members or member would
report to— Yeah, so we could have whoever we want, you know,
managing the program, you know, from city staff as well
as, you know, any board members. I pick Brad.
He's decent. It's probably Zach,
but— And I would say that there's enough out there, that there's
policies already in place, Salt Lake City specifically. Do you know
of some that you can point them to? I can find it, I can find
them. So then if we adopt it as a policy, is there still head
nods, still support to— Yeah, and I think the
liability form's easy. We can get 1,000 parents to sign the liability form
for bounce houses. every year at Pony Express Days. I'm not worried about
12 people doing gardens. So— Well, they would need to do a contract
anyway with whatever they're doing. They would need to do a contract anyway with whatever
they're doing, and part of that contract could be a section about liability.
Um, the only thing I would caution on that is if you do charge residents
for that, we want to make sure that we follow all financial policies and the
cash collection. We budget the revenue, we budget the expenditures that we might have
out of it. I mean, is that what you guys would like us to do
if we went this route, to charge?
Okay, I think that's gonna have to be part
of the policy, is what the fee is, how that's handled, and how you collect
sponsorships. Yes, the first one's going to come from Councilmember Wright.
He'll vote no and then he'll write you a check.
That's possible. Perfect. But I
think that's part of it. So with that, I think we gotta keep moving.
Do you have clear— ask questions. Okay, so are we good then if we
do go forward in the Community Services Board and create a subcommittee and
at least bring you a policy before anything gets started to have for approval?
I think that's the case, yes. And make sure that the policy has
all the items that we listed, the financial aspect, the Signage,
things like that. Liability. The liability waiver. Compliance with existing financial
policy. Yeah, compliance with existing financial policy. So if
you'll sign that,
or if that means that it's just you, one of you two, but assign that
policy, writing the policy, if I can think.
Yes, okay. And then get it with Ben and Marcus Then
we'll, uh, I'll write that policy. Yes. Okay, is that
good? Thank you very much. Okay, thank you.
All right, moving along. We good? I feel like I'm
a little out of sort. So,
um, moving on to our agenda. I know we'll get through this
as quick as we can, which I think we can, uh, to get to our
closed session. Uh, I do know that we had a really good time I
shouldn't say good time, a really busy time in New York. But is there any
other, uh, Item 3, City Manager information
items? Sure, I'll just cover a few things really quick. Um,
I just— there's a lot of things that we should be thanking our staff for
at this period of time. Um, I know it's been a very difficult time for
our community, but the amount of work that has been involved in completing the audit
and completing the budget and, and even going through with the tax increase and all
of the, um, follow-up items from election to grandma requests and
all that. So I just want to extend appreciation. I know the council has
wanted a lot of information from staff, and they've been, uh, very buried
with, with other things, such as coming up with, um, all the information
needed for our sewer treatment bond and all the different work that has been going
on in different areas. And so we've tried to manage that and try to manage
getting requests back. And so we thank the community, and we Thank the council for
your patience, and I thank the staff for their efforts involved in that.
With that said, October kicks off the 2000 FY
2026 audit as well as the FY 27 budget.
So here we are again, and look forward to a happy
new year. And with that said, there has been a lot of information gathering
and whatnot so that we can be well prepared for our sewer treatment plant
expansion. The mayor mentioned that we went through a bond
rating exercise with S&P and Fitch to be able to
share the story of our community and do so in a way that
will show the opportunities and the good things happening and
hopefully lower our interest rates, which would save our residents millions of dollars
over the life of that bond. And so I can't extend
enough appreciation to all the staff that helped us prepare
and those that had the honor of going and sharing our story. I think it
was a very successful event, and it was an honor to be part of that
group. Also today, we took a tour of Williams that's
doing the construction of the power plant down— facility
down south of Meta. That's a $1.7 billion
investment into our community, and it was exciting to take a tour and
see all the good things that are going on there. Thank you. They have 300
jobs in place between now and 2028 while they're doing that work.
And so that's a significant increase in taxable value for
our community that will hit the books in 2028 and 2029. The construction
will be completed in '27 and '28, so that's why it's a year later.
And that's why some of the issues— we have some good things happening in our
future, but it doesn't hit the books until a little bit further out. And of
course, you need the power before you have the other benefits
from other development in the area. With that said, we have a number of projects
that are kicking off right now. Many of you have probably seen the Trailhead intersection
work start at the intersection of Trailhead and Pony Express where we will have
a new signal light. Campus Drive and Ranches Parkway will have its
improvements with a high-T intersection improved there.
The Scarlet Tank Ridge tank is moving Moving forward, about 10 months
left on that tank construction.
We've had a lot of improvements in work on wells of late. I know
Well 2 is up and running now. I know it had some issues,
but it is up and running. So we appreciate our staff being able to bring
that up and solve the issues that were related
to that maintenance issue. And Well 8 should be up and running in October.
Good things are happening there, and I think you can see it not only in,
in the community at large, but in our soccer fields. I think our soccer fields
are looking exceptionally good. I've had compliments coming in from the community
about those soccer fields and some of the improvements there, and I think we're all
seeing it in our yards with the blessing of the rain that we've had of
late too. So good things are happening in our community, and I just want to
extend appreciation to the council for all your continued support.
Yeah, and just, uh, when you're talking about the staff, also I'm gonna add our
consultants. Uh, Laura Lewis put a really good presentation together,
and then her staff, uh, I don't know them all, but that
was super successful. Um, any questions
on any of that? I know that was fast, just wanna make sure everybody's up
to speed. Okay, uh, let's go through the consent agenda real quick.
I, I think this is pretty easy. 10, uh, item 10A is the change order,
the White Hills 4 million gallon tank, and this is
the final kind of closeout. Were there any questions?
I know Vince is here to answer questions. Okay, anything that you
need to add? It doesn't sound okay. Item 11A: The minutes for our
regular city council meeting on August 18th and the
August 26th special meeting. Okay, the preliminary
plat for Gateway Park Phase Three. I would like for us to
pull that from the. consent agenda so we can discuss that a little bit.
There were some things that came up during Planning Commission. This is for
the charter school, right? That I think would be useful for us as
a body just to quick talk about. So if you guys are willing. OK,
thank you. I agree with that. Nothing that we could solve now, right? So it's
just— OK, so we'll go ahead and pull that off and put it on the
regularly scheduled items.
A is a resolution of Eagle Mountain City approving the 2nd amendment to the Briley
Farms Phase B development agreement.
So did, did the applicant do what we asked them
to do? Yeah, they, they took it from the 40 with 600-foot garages to
the 20 that they've already built with 600-foot garages and 40
more that will have the 400 and— what is it,
490-something? And that was the size we were asking Well,
yes, that, that was what they demonstrated to us last time, so they actually
added an additional— what they did is we reduced it on 20 and they added
20 more. So I wanted to just thank you for that, for listening, and that
makes sense to me at this point. So we're comfortable leaving that
on the consent agenda. Thanks for coming. That was easy.
The 13B is resolution of Eagle Mountain City to become an official
member of the North Utah County Aquifer Council.
No questions yet?
No. And then 14A is ordinance of Eagle Mountain City amending
the Municipal Code 245.010,
the Youth Council term limits. And I wanted to make sure this— you
had a lot of— yeah, it looks good to me. It represented what you said
last night. That's great. Okay. And any other questions on that one?
14B, an ordinance of Eagle Mountain City amending the Eagle Mountain Municipal Code 3.30
regarding land disposals. This has to do with the
map. We don't have the map yet,
but this has to do with the state law changes. So we're updating
our code to conform to those changes. Okay,
and no other questions on that one that I can see? Okay,
the rest are scheduled items. I think
because of what we have to discuss, unless there's specific questions that need
changes between now and then that we could hurry and go over— is there anything
that you know of that we need to, uh, to work
on? Yeah,
you're good. There's nothing. Okay, go ahead.
Hey, Mayor, I move the council adjourn to a closed session pursuant
to Section 52-4- 205 subsection
1 of the Utah Code Annotated. Second.
Okay, we have a motion by Councilmember Whiting, a second by Councilmember
Clark, and we'll start the vote with Councilmember Whiting. Yes. And Councilmember Hewish.
Yes. Councilmember Clark. Yes. Councilmember Wright. Yes.
Okay, and that motion passes.
Yeah, and I was going to say that later, that Rich was
missing, but we'll get that in the policy session.
So You're
good. You're good. All right.
It's 7 o'clock. We're gonna get started.
Before we get started, I've asked Stephen to start us
Our Father in heaven, we're so very grateful for this
chance that we've been blessed with as citizens
of the city and staff members and those that we come
together to discuss those issues that are important to us that affect
all of our lives. We pray
that we may be cordial with one another, that we can be responsible
and thoughtful in our words and actions.
We ask that we may be guided in the
decisions that are made and the responses that
we feel are appropriate.
We ask thee as we end tonight that we
all may return back to our respective homes in safety and get
the rest that we need for the coming day.
And these things we pray for in the name of Jesus Christ, amen. Amen.
All right, it is 7:02, and I'll officially
call this meeting adjourned. Meeting to order of the Eagle Mountain City Council on September
1st, 2026. And before we get started, Council Member Whiting's
going to lead us in the Pledge of Allegiance. Please rise, join with me.
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the United States
of America and to the Republic for which it stands,
one nation under God, indivisible,
with liberty and justice for all.
Okay, first of all, before we get started, I just wanted to excuse Councilmember Wood.
He's got some personal issues that he's taking care of, so we'll
excuse him from tonight's meeting. If he gets a chance, he may join us online
if that happens. So, um,
First of all, Mr.
Reeves, is there any information items? We do have some. Thank you,
Mayor. First of all, we have the EM30, the Eagle
Mountain 30-Year Anniversary Challenge that has kicked off today.
Stephen, do you want to talk about that? Steve?
Yeah, the EM30 Challenge is exciting.
It's going to be September through November. So it ends just before our actual
30th anniversary on December 3rd. And it's
a challenge similar to the Walk 250 with America 250 that's
to inspire people to get outside, recreate, especially here in Eagle Mountain,
hike, bike, walk, run,
and then there's a bunch of other options if you're not able to get out
and do that, to read 30. So we call it kind of
Bike 30 or Hike 30 or Run 30 or Or read 30,
or sew 30, or serve 30, or do a lot of different
things to celebrate the 30th anniversary of the city. And then there's
a way to submit your completion of that
online, and you'll get an exclusive 30th anniversary
sticker and then be entered into a drawing for prizes.
Thank you. We also have, in conjunction with that, the America 250.
It's our 250th anniversary for our nation, and there's
a pop-up museum at the Cedar Valley High School on September 2nd,
tomorrow, from 4 to 8 PM. Of course, a reminder that our farmers
market is every Saturday, 9 AM to 1 PM through October 10th at
Corey Ride Park. Our Constitution boot camp,
Wednesday, September 9th, from 7 to 8 PM at
Cedar Valley High School. Stargazing, Wednesday, September 9th,
from 8 to 9 PM at Walden Park. Utah's statewide
virtual job fair, Thursday, September 10th, from 10 AM
to 1 PM on jobs.utah.gov.
There is a walk to fight suicide Thursday, September 10th,
at 6 PM to 8 PM at Cedar Valley Football Field.
There's a scorpion hunt Friday, September 11th,
8:30 PM. Meet at City Hall, Council Chambers.
September 11th Day of Service is going to actually— is on Friday,
September 11th, including Hero Parade at the elementary school and
flag ceremony at Cedar Valley High School.
We have Shop Fest Saturday, September 12th from 9 to 5 PM at
Corey Wright Park. Days of Service— this is in conjunction with
the September 11th, but ours— our Days of Service were going to be held this
year on September 15th, Tuesday through Thursday,
September 17th. So we have many activities planned throughout our community,
and we invite the community to participate.
Our fall dumpsters will be here for cleanup Wednesday, September 16th through Wednesday,
September 23rd at Quarry Ride Park.
And we have an exciting announcement: Eagle Mountain's
own Xavier Gozo, who came up through Real
Salt Lake organization, has signed a five-year deal with.
Crystal Palace FC, making him the first player from Utah
to reach the Premier League, arguably the top soccer league
in the world. So we want to congratulate him.
Yeah, that was fun. I saw the news when we were working
on that bond, and it was, it's kind of fun to see an Eagle Mountain
native get that recognition, make it in the pro sports.
Thank you, Ben. Our next item, 8, this is the time set aside for public
comment. As a reminder, public comment is an opportunity for
community members to address the City Council, and each speaker is allowed up to 3
minutes. If you wish to speak during the public comment, the public hearing
portion, please complete a comment form located in the back and return
it to our recorder on this side, and we will recognize
you during the public comment or during the public hearing portion.
Council members will listen but not engage in discussions during public
comment. We ask that everyone remain respectful. Disrespect— disruptive
behavior including cheering, booing, clapping, comments directed at individual
city employees is not prohibited— is not allowed— is
prohibited. If you have issues or questions regarding
staff or personnel, administrative staff will meet you in the foyer for further discussion.
So let us know if that's a case, and our assistant Steve will meet
you out in the foyer. Lastly, public comment period is for items not associated
with this public— the scheduled public hearing. If your comment relates to public
hearing item, please wait till that item is called. Tonight's public hearings are 15A,
that's the code to repeal and replace the Section 1760 regarding
retaining wall construction, and 15B, which is
the ordinance rezoning lands,
certain lands known as Pinnacles, and approving the Pinnacles Master Development Plan and
Master Development Agreement. So at 7:08, I will open the public
hearing or the public comment period.
And— Yeah, we have Jason Ayu.
Jason Ayu.
You're good now. Okay. Good evening, Mayor, Council.
My name is Jason Ayew. My wife and I, my wife Joanne and I,
have been here for 26 years in Eagle Mountain. This is our home, this is
our community, and we're excited to be able to discuss item
12A, which is a plat. And on that plat, you're gonna hear about our site
plan for a school that we propose. It's a charter school called Ripple Academy.
Having my children have born
and raised here in Eagle Mountain and have been great products of the public school
system. One thing that I've learned from my own 2 children is that
both, even though living in the same home, they both have 2 completely different
learning styles. And my son Chaz thrived really well in a traditional
learning, moved on and went to college, graduated from college. My daughter Zion,
not so much. She really struggle with the traditional learning style. And so
Ripple Academy is a life-based learning
model that, you know, thinking about as we develop this school,
it really would've been fantastic for my daughter Zion
to be in this school. But we can't go backwards, we can only move forward.
And, you know, as we put some initial interest out
there, our school proposes hopefully will be open by next August 2027
if everything goes well, knock on wood. But we've already had over 300
members, 300 members of Eagle Mountain that have expressed interest into that
learning-based model of Ripple Academy. And so we just want to put
a name and a face in front of you as you— I'm sure you'll hear
from us many times forward, but thank you for your time and hopefully we
appreciate your support in getting our site plan approved. So thank you.
Anthony Wood.
How's it going? I put my comment
down under item 16, but it was— it's not really directed towards
that. Essentially, I wanted to say thank
you guys. Thank you for, you know, listening to us and
working together with residents. In regards to that truth in taxation, we did. I know
you guys were facing a lot of varying degrees of criticism,
and much of it seemed to be pretty distasteful.
I know you guys had a lot of late nights and very long conversations
helping everyone figure it out and get the information out there.
I appreciate we were able to come together and come to a very reasonable number.
I found myself talking to a lot of residents.
Many of them were blaming council members for all of the truth in taxation
stuff. And I found myself telling them a story and
that they needed to realize that they were slightly accountable as well.
Now, that story was essentially just imagine that your family
is the city. You know, you're the city council. Your spouse
is the mayor. Your kids are the residents.
You know, your family is pregnant, you have another kid on the way,
and you start saving up for a new car because you need one.
You know, after a few doctor visits, you find out you're having triplets,
and now that car is not going to do. You need a minivan.
It's going to cost a lot more money. You go to your family, you tell
them like, hey, I'm going to cut back on your allowances because we need
to finance this vehicle we can't quite afford, but we need it now.
No. You hear crickets. You come back a couple
days later, you tell them again. Again, no response. Crickets.
Now, what I was telling everyone is that, you know,
they get all mad when they find out that their allowances were cut.
You know, what are you doing? What are you doing? You know, you're cutting my
allowance back. You know, oh, we had to get that van. Well,
they'll start replying with like, we didn't need that van. Who told you we needed
that? Like, we don't need it. It's too expensive. where are you putting the money?
We could have done something different. You know, all those crickets during the first
conversations were us residents not coming to the first few meetings and discussing
everything and figuring it all out. Ultimately,
I was telling them that if you want to know what's going on, or,
you know, if you want to complain and have some value behind it, you need
to come to the meetings and listen and know what's going on.
I heard some residents talking about how 30 seconds
remaining. Some residents were complaining about
like, oh, you know, we didn't discuss this. I want to know this, I want
to know this. And I was literally sending them dates of when we were having
council meetings in the past where you guys covered that. And I was sending them
video clips from those meetings.
And it's like, they discussed it, you weren't there. I just wanted to say thank
you though, so.
All right, that's everybody that's turned in a form. Is there anybody that
did not get an opportunity that would like to speak at this time?
Seeing no one, we will close the public comment period
at 7:13 and bring it back to the council. And,
uh, for this time has been set aside for them to make comments
and address the public. We'll start with Councilmember Clark.
Thank you, Mayor, and thank you for your thoughts.
Ironically, I have a set of twins, and we only had one
kid when we found out we were having them, and we had to move
to a minivan too, and it was a major life change. It,
like, we didn't fit in the car that we had anymore, and it
was a pretty big deal. So, like, I really got
the visual of what you shared. Thank you.
I have to remind myself when people get mad
at me or call me something on Facebook that the only difference between
me and the people who are saying what they're saying on Facebook is information.
And we're working hard to improve what we do as far
as information goes and getting that information out to you. And we're,
we're patient with our residents because we know what it feels like to be
angry about something or confused. Or afraid.
So give us, give us a
little bit of grace as we work through finding out information about how
to get you information. One of the things that we discussed during our work session
today was our normal community survey that we do
each year, and one of the questions that we talked about was finding
out from our residents what's the best way to communicate with you,
what mode of communication is going to actually serve
serve you the best. And I think that attention to detail is something that gets
missed by people who aren't here sitting
up on the dais. But we want you to know that we,
we really do want you to be a part of the process. We believe in
your ability to help us make decisions, and we're grateful that you're here.
And I just want to say too how grateful I am for our staff.
They put in countless hours. I know our recorder's office had
to get a packet ready, then they had to get a bunch of other stuff
ready and meet deadlines. And they're not the only ones
that are just busting their tails to make things go in our city.
And I just am super grateful. We wouldn't be able to be who we are
without you guys. So thank you.
Thank you, Mayor. Yeah, thank you, Mr. Wood. I appreciate your comments.
We've taken it on the chin for a few weeks, and it's nice to hear
somebody that actually appreciates what we do. Whether we get it right or wrong,
we know that we do both. I mean, I recognize
that, at least I get it that way. Sometimes I get it wrong,
and hopefully that's a minor amount of the time, and more
often than not, we make good decisions. I call them SUDs,
seemingly unimportant decisions, and we make Lots of them. And I
think that the more that we can make in a positive manner that
bring positive results, that ultimately those benefits and
blessings will come up and they show up on our doorstep. So seemingly unimportant
decisions that we make daily, weekly, yearly as we sit
here and have the opportunity to make those decisions on your behalf.
So thank you for your words. Welcome to all
of you that are here. It's good to see some smiling faces. Mr. Ayoub,
you don't know me, but I know your dad pretty well.
And what an awesome man your father
is. And so thank you for being— I didn't know that you're a member of
our community, so that makes me happy. I've only been here 22 years,
not 26. So you got me beat there.
And then I want to just— I guess I want to make this point.
And I know that the council members know this. I met with the seniors today,
the senior citizens. I'm the liaison for the city with the senior citizens from
the city council, and they expressed some concerns
and some issues that they're having that are not unlike what our staff members deal
with. They need more room. They've got more members
of their community that want to come and they want to participate in their building.
We added a building there 2 years ago, 3 years ago.
Was it last year? Last year. It's— and they've outgrown it already. And it was
just a trailer. It's just a Connex. It's an extra, right?
What do they call them at the school? A pod of some portable of
some sort. And we were fortunate that we had some federal funds that allowed
us to do that. Didn't come out of our taxpayer dollars, at least locally.
It came out of some federal funds. And so I'm asking the council to consider
perhaps directing some of those CBDG funds in that direction towards
them. But it also underlines at least a major concern
that I have is For our staff members, we're looking at hiring some new people.
For every person we hire, we probably need 3 that we should be hiring.
And for every person that we hire, that's just,
that's just 10 more people that are having to work out of closets or from
home or remotely. And I don't think our citizens really see that
impact, but I'm, I've been here long enough now that I'm, I'm seeing that and
we just lose efficiencies when we have to function that way. So I hope that
you'll bear with us as we make many hard decisions. We're talking about a sewer
treatment plant, huge bond. But if you want that
stuff to go where it's supposed to do, we have to make the right decisions,
right? So I just, I want to express my love and
my gratitude to each of you for allowing me the
opportunity to serve. I'm nothing special.
I don't know a whole lot, and I've learned even more having
out here, but what I can promise you is that every decision
that I make, I will always do it—
I will always make it asking this question: What's in the best interest
of the people who are members of my community, myself, my family,
and you who are here in attendance tonight? So thank you.
Welcome, everybody. It's great to have you. Go Cougs.
Thank you. Wow, yeah, this last,
last month or so has been quite, quite a month for us up here.
And I've thought about a lot of things, learned a lot from residents
and shared a lot in return. And I just wanted to make a couple comments.
You know, when we communicate with one another, you can
either assume ill intent from the beginning and begin your relationship that way, or you
can assume good intent and begin it that
way and then make decisions from there. A quote that I like, great minds discuss
ideas, average minds discuss events, and small minds discuss people.
Well, when it came to the tax discussions, some people kept
it at the idea level, and ideas were going back and forth.
Then at the end of the day, after ideas were discussed, people could say,
well, I agree with that approach, or I don't agree with that approach, but it
didn't get personal. It was just, I have a different managerial style or a different
vision. And there's no animosity in that. But I found there were
a lot of people that stayed down at the people level instead of discussing
ideas level, and they just wanted to attack character and attack,
you know, just attack and assume ill intent.
And I don't think that's safe for a marriage. And when
you have a marriage companionship, you know, you should hopefully assume good intent and that
if there's been a miscommunication, it's usually been There's been a miscommunication,
but I'm grateful for the for the residents that that kept
the discussion on ideas because when that happened, solutions came
out and bridge building came out. And I think that's a lot where we
where we need to keep keep our discussions at the idea at the idea
stage instead of it attacking character stage.
And I recognize as public officials we're going to get you
know we're going to get some of the character attacks and that that's going to
happen and. I would just invite people to come meet with us first and then
make a decision if you want to about our character after you come actually meet
with us. We live in your same neighborhoods. We ride the same, drive on the
same roads, go to the same schools, cheer for the same Cedar Valley High School
football team, and we're in the stands with you. Just come say hi to
us. Come meet us. I homeschool my kids, and then
my kids have done some various things with the public school as well, and I
love the diverse opportunities for learning because you're right,
all, you know, our minds don't, you know, all think
the same way and we do need different ways to be able to learn and
grow. So I'm excited to have the discussion a little bit later about
that school you have going in. Thanks for bringing that. And that,
again, that's the idea phase, right? The ideas that bring
solutions. That's more what we need. We need more ideas and we're better
together when we can share ideas with one another. So Thanks for your patience with
us as we work through this process. I actually gained
more friends from this than I probably gained maybe some enemies as well,
but I don't consider them enemies, and they might consider me an enemy.
But I met some people I didn't know before that I'm like, wow, I have
much respect for, gained greater respect for in this process.
And so I'm grateful for the people that reached out and took the time to
actually get to know us, have legitimate discussions that moved
the city forward.
Yeah, thank you, Anthony, for making that comment.
I had a coworker yesterday, she came to my office and she said,
you're famous. I was like, really? She said,
yeah, my daughter's been following everything on your city on TikTok.
Like, that's not how I wanted to get famous,
but that's okay. Everybody now in America knows
about property taxes in Eagle Mountain.
You know, I look at all the positives that have come from this.
Tonight we're proposing code that would not have existed
had we not had an active conversation in the city.
We'll hopefully be putting in place a safety fund that
when you pay your property tax, 100% of
That will go into a safety fund segregated from sales tax. That's something
that didn't— has never existed, as far as I know, in our city.
We'll be creating, hopefully, if it passes, a rebalancing
mechanism for city councils to not just kick the can down the road, you know,
to have some kind of mechanism. Do we need to save up for a car?
Do we need to consider that we are having triplets,
and how do we plan for that? We're also
going to be working on a budget in brief, a very simple 10-page
document that is at an 18-year-old level. Somebody who can vote
can read it and understand what's happening in the budget
for the next year. So there's a lot of positive things I think that came
from it. There's some negative things. There are certainly things that we've learned and things
that we'll work on and improve next go-round. So I look at
it and I think There are a lot of positive things that have come from
it. And I'm just grateful. I think the one thing
that we all have in common is we all love Eagle
Mountain and we all want what's best. And sometimes that's gonna be crossing
swords and sharpening our swords. But I, you know, I love what Craig's
comment was. If we can focus on the ideas and
come together with the best ideas, that's a huge
positive. Thank you. So anyways, I'm just grateful. I'm grateful for the
residents. I'm grateful for the process. It has been difficult,
but I'm thankful for where we're landed.
All right, thank you. Appreciate the comments. And just add that, yeah, I too
love the things that we've learned. I look around
and I think of all the really, really smart people, and one of them might
be Scott Hazard. Smartest guys I know in the city.
And when I was able to talk to him about some of the things that
we were working on, he says, well, I didn't know that. I'm like, I knew
something that Scott didn't know? That was like floored me, right? So it was,
uh, it was definitely a learning experience, and especially with people that I really look
up to, uh, to be able to do that. I also,
uh, did get the opportunity to live next to the Ayus, and I really appreciate
their ideas, uh, although I'm not going to admit whether it was my brother or
not that might put a U in your front yard or not. I don't know
anything about that, but I know that he also got one, so it might
not have been him. But no, it's super fun to be neighbors. You're actually—
you didn't know this, but on the other side of the hill, your backyards almost
touch. So just on the other side of the hill. But the— yeah,
it's super fun to see everybody come with their ideas. And I
love the public when they get to come out and I thought Melissa
would say it. I'm actually disappointed. When people come and yell at
us like that, it's just people caring loudly, right? Isn't that the show from
Parks and Rec, right? I just hear people caring loudly.
So no, it's super fun. So thanks for all your input. I was
gonna add the last few, last month has been a
whirlwind, but we had the opportunity to go spend some time saving
the city a lot of money. I think, over the years. And last week,
me and a couple of staffers went back to New York and
was able to help improve our bond rating. Just the work
that was done there and the things that our staff does and our consultants,
we had Laura Lewis with us, and it's just amazing. And then
the people that were here trying to meet deadlines on,
with the county and getting agendas ready. Thank you. And our attorneys
reviewing documents and just the planning staff.
Everybody was just, it has been a whirlwind. And so grateful
for all the work that we're getting done and even constrained that we're
able to really, really move the needle, I feel like, and do some cool things
and hopefully save a lot of money and be able to keep that budget lean.
So with that, I think we'll get started. And I know
the first item We talked about in the, the work session, the consent agenda item
12A might get moved to the— Yep.
Would you accept a motion, Mayor? Yes, sir. Yes, ma'am. Mayor, I move
that the City Council approve the consent agenda, removing item 12A
from the consent agenda and placing it on the scheduled items
section of the agenda. Second. Okay, we have
a motion by Councilmember Clark and a second by Councilmember Wright. And we'll
start the vote with Councilmember Hewish. Yes. Councilmember Clark.
Yes. Councilmember Wright. Yes. Councilmember Whiting.
Yes. Just, I just wanted to double-check. Councilmember Wood never, he did not join,
right? Okay. Just making sure I didn't miss a vote.
That passes 4 to 0. And we'll go right to
item 12A, the Gateway Park.
And I know, Steven, turn it to you.
All right. Thank you.
Do you have a screen coming?
I'm patient this time.
All right.
Okay. Yeah, it seems like some of you are familiar with this. That's why it's
been pulled off the agenda. This is a preliminary plat. Applications kind of come through
quickly in attempts to help the proposed school to meet deadlines that
they have to get this open when they want to. So the property
we're dealing with is near the intersection of Mount Airy Drive
and Corby Ride Highway. So it's just west of Enbridge
here and And Eagle Mountain Storage. So it's this little area here.
Here's a shot of the preliminary plat.
So it's a 3-lot plat.
Lot 1 is where the proposed school would be. It's a 6-acre lot.
And then lots 2 and 3 would be, I'm guessing,
just later phases of this development.
Here's it again. So, go back
to this. So, as I'm looking at this,
our Transportation Master Plan, so this is Wagstaff Way, so this would be the north
end of that preliminary plat, and then this road is there on the western edge,
just some context. So we're looking at a future minor
arterial and then a future collector road.
So, this is, this plat that we're dealing with tonight,
And then kind of gives you some context there is that you look at the
Spring Run Plaza development, so you can kind of see where Wagstaff Way is
looking to connect there. There will be a gap for the time being as
those 2 roads develop, um, but eventually those will come together and form that connection.
Uh, as we're reviewing it, there were 2 points that we want to bring up.
So the first one is our code doesn't allow on preliminary plats
to have lots front arterial and collector streets.
Uh, in this case, I think staff's comfortable with allowing that, seeing as
unless— like, we, we talked to the developer— unless they can find a way to
do it, it's kind of tricky to do with a school and have them still
function the way they need to. Uh, right now,
the school's been proposing 2, um,
ingress-egress points out of their property, and they're as far away from the intersection as
possible. So we were— we think with the other 2
lots, We're looking at maybe 1 or 2 or 3 additional
points out onto those collector roads. So I feel like if it's— it's not
necessarily an important standard to hold to in this case.
And then the second one would be that western collector road.
Go back. So this one right here, right now the developer is proposing it be
named Gateway Park Boulevard.
This will eventually connect up to Wild Blossom Boulevard in
Saratoga Springs. With our recent code change that was approved,
and just looking at it, I think staff feels that that name
of Wild Blossom should probably continue just for coherency. Yes, it does,
it will split the boundary between Saratoga Springs and Eagle Mountain, but I
think it'll just create coherency on that road and make it easier to traverse
and to find addresses and— Thank you.
the cohesion between those 2. So those are the 2,
um, conditions— that, that be renamed, and then if we're okay with not
letting them have those access points onto the roads.
I asked for this to be removed from the consent agenda because I want to
talk about the name of the road.
I get that for our code we've made it a priority
for us to have roads contiguous have
the same name. However, I think where
I draw the line with that is where it runs into another city. Um,
we have Woodhaven that is going to eventually
connect to something over in Saratoga Springs, and we have Silver Lake Parkway
that's going down to eventually connect with the new high school.
And I don't see on any planet us Entertaining changing
the name once it gets to a certain point,
and Wild Blossom is a very design-specific
name for the housing development
that's there. And we have other streets
in that general vicinity: Ranches Parkway, we have Spring
Run, and I just think that. The project
in this area will be better served with sticking to the overall
name of Gateway Park Boulevard.
One, I just had a question. I know I don't have a lot of say
on this, but the driveway situation, I know staff said they didn't
mind or that maybe it fit. I just wanted to raise the question what we've
done in the past, and specifically residential. This— I
don't remember the parking lot, but can you go back to the— well, actually,
speaking of Woodhaven, there are 3 homes that are
on basically on Woodhaven, and we've cut that, uh, you know,
there's that big C-shaped half moon so that
if someone was backing out of their driveway, they could get forward and go out.
Is it, uh— I don't have my stuff,
but with the plat, is there room to make some
kind of a cutout like that, would that address a concern? I think you
just have to ask the developer that question, Mayor, because it really is dependent upon
the internal, the internal construction.
Well, and I think my, my point was with council, if we're not okay,
would that be a solution? I just wanted to point that out, and, and I'm
happy to let you address that if there is a concern.
I don't know there is. I just wanted to bring that because
it was addressed. Go ahead.
Okay, is this not work— oh hey, it's working now. It wasn't working a week
ago. Um, Scott Hazard, I'm, I'm the developer,
one of the applicants. Uh, to answer your question, Mayor, these are
not 6, 8, 10,000 square foot lots. This is a 6-acre parcel.
Um, the intention you heard earlier is for a charter school site,
so they'll have circulated egress that comes One off of Wagstaff
Way and then one off of Gateway Park
Boulevard, if you so see it that way.
There really is no way to load this internally. If you recall the
collaboration for Wagstaff Way and for Gateway Park
Boulevard, these collectors and arterials that run through our
600-acre master plan that we'll be bringing to you shortly, we're advancing this. Thank you.
us accelerate it more quickly to meet the timeline of the charter school.
Um, but this— all of those, uh,
larger roadways were, were programmed
and designed in collaboration with, uh, David Salazar and with the,
with city staff. They did not exist when we put in the original,
uh, Gateway Park improvements with the storage garages, the flex space,
the Enbridge facility, etc. So there was no contemplation
to try to work an internal road to try to create like a little horseshoe
or half moon is just a waste of property, I think, on a
6-acre lot. The other lots are not 6 acres, but they're also significant in size.
And the south side of Wagstaff Way, so between
Wagstaff Way and State Road 73, is a tapering
traffic route according to our modeling because it connects to
a right-in, right-out. Most of the traffic will, in the modeling,
will either go to Spring Run Parkway, the signalized
full-service intersection when UDOT expands that facility,
or it'll go eastbound to Mount Airy Drive where there's another signalized
intersection. Scott, that was one of the questions that I had. Mayor, may I just
jump in here? And it's really, so until UDOT does the expansion,
what is the plan for the connectivity to Whatever
the name of this road is going to be. Yeah, this kind of the S-shape
that you have right now for the right-in, right-out, is that going to— are you
guys— is that going to be developed? So that's what we'll connect to. That S-curve
has been paved from— I mean, it's been paved for a really long time.
So that was permitted when we sold the corridor preservation
parcel to UDOT. We sold them about 8 acres along our frontage.
We wanted to maintain the access. We put the permit in.
Typically, the permit requires a road like that to be on a property
line, but in this case it didn't because of the topography.
We had to create— UDOT required us to create a safe egress
road, which required us to kind of run that up parallel grade and
snake it up the hill. So that's why it's snaky, is because it's going
up that hill. The property line's smack in the middle of it,
if you can see that yellow line. So when UDOT's facilities in there, what does
that look like? Is it a right-in, right-out right at the base of where the
mayor's cursor's at? It'll tie to a frontage road. So when UDOT expands— so
for now it goes to the right-in, right-out on the existing facility. Right now the
program— the programming for the expansion design is when it's completed, it'll tie
to the frontage road, and then the freeway or arterial traffic
will go in the middle, similar to what you see at 2100 North. I think
it's a similar road profile. Thank you. I think what I was gonna say,
my point when I was talking about the C or the half-moon entrances
onto the lot, was there residential lots and they're backing out?
There won't be anybody backing out onto the collector. No, all of this
is charter school, and then there's these other 2 lots here that are intended to
mirror a use that's similar to what we did here, some flex space or something
along those lines. So showing these entrances, they're gonna be pulling out into the road
just like any other? Correct. And you'll see that on the site plan for
the charter school when it comes before you to determine whether or not the way
they're proposing that access and circulation makes sense to you.
But from what I've seen, they're looking to access one here on Wagstaff Way and
then circulate out here onto Gateway Park Boulevard.
If I could just say one thing about Gateway Park Boulevard, obviously we're not
excited to brand a major master planned community in another city,
which is why we're proposing the name change. And because we're a significant grouping
or massing of land, we've got about 600 acres there eventually, we wanted
it to be destination-oriented. We're— when
you're on Ranches Parkway, you're in the ranches and you know that.
So, but Wild Blossom is primarily an east-west road.
It only curves to the south at the very
last little bit to connect into our north property line. So the
vast majority of that right-of-way going north-south would be a whole
different coordinate set. So I think that should be taken into consideration
in addition to we're crossing a boundary with another city. And I just wanted to
add one more thing as you talk master plan for the council to consider.
If the entrances are, say, here and here that we just talked about,
without a master plan, is there any kind of an assurance
that we could have that The future development of something over here is not going
to have an entrance, you know, they're going to line up is what I'm getting
at. They're not going to be offset intersections so that if you have an entrance,
you know, here, that you'd also have one here to a business on
this side. Yeah, so this,
this is programmed as a commercial lot. Um,
so, Mayor, I get the, I get the point, and I think we can work
to make sure that that's safe. I'm sure whatever we bring for development on this,
we would collaborate with staff and try to have some intelligent safe design there.
This parcel is becoming more and more constrained due to the RCA
approval that at best is creating an 18-foot
cut where it hits my southern property line, which really affects the ability—
like, I can't load from this lot on that whole side, and I can't
for hundreds and hundreds of feet to the north because I just— it's a tunnel.
So I'm going to have to load somewhat from Wagstaff Way
or from this side to be able to even make that property work. I just
want to make sure there's some kind of contemplation of lining that up.
This— what if you're going to load off this side, that there's a—
they're across from each other? Yeah, I think we could work to make sure that
that makes sense moving forward. Just know that it'll most likely have to load from
that side because we have new constraints that we didn't anticipate on the
I'm ready to make a motion. I think we should call it IU Boulevard instead,
but I'll make this motion. Craig,
before you do that, can I just ask a question? Oh, yeah, go ahead.
How does the council feel about the name? I think Gateway Park Boulevard.
I like it. It comes to me, it comes down to branding, and we're a
different city, so I'm okay having it be— Okay, that's what I wanted to hear.
Okay, so I move that City Council approve the Gateway Park Plat 3 preliminary
plat with condition number 1,
omitting condition number 2. Second.
Okay, we have a motion by Councilmember Whiting and a second by Councilmember Clark,
and we'll start the vote with Councilmember Clark? Yes. Councilmember Wright?
Yes. Councilmember Whiting? Yes. Councilmember Hewish?
Yes. Okay, that motion passes.
Thank you. Appreciate your time. And we'll move to item 14—
nope, 15A. And that's an ordinance of Eagle Mountain City,
Utah, amending the Eagle Mountain Municipal Code to repeal
and replace Section 1760130,
regarding retaining walls and construction standards.
Um, we'll invite Vince. There you are.
You probably see me here a little better, I think.
Mayor and Council, it's good to be with you. We'll get this pulled up here
and we can get started.
Okay. I'll warn you, this is a
lot of engineering and technical stuff that we're going to talk about.
Hopefully you have your engineering hats on.
As I've been here for the last couple years, this is
one of the codes that has come up kind of over and over again,
not just from an engineering standpoint, but from planning and from our building
inspectors. And it became pretty obvious
that there were some weaknesses in the previous code that we wanted to address.
And so, This is a conglomeration
of engineering and planning and the building
inspectors all meeting together and kind of coming up with what we think is best.
So why we're updating the standard.
The old standard, if you remember, it had
specific types of materials called out
and And it was kind of based on those specific types of walls
or types of materials of walls. We wanted to go away from
that a little bit and base it more on an engineering basis.
There was nothing in the old code about surcharge loading on
top of these walls. And we'll talk a little bit more about what surcharge
load is in just a minute. But we wanted to address that.
Height limits, a set 6-foot for absolutely
everything. A lot of requests for variances to this,
and so we tried to address that one too.
And then in the old code, there was no formal inspection program
required. And so once it got through the city review process,
they would go out and build it, and it wasn't always built according to what
we had specced out. So to
kind of simplify things, we said, let's just divide
this into 2 main categories, prescriptive gravity
walls and engineering retaining walls. The gravity
walls are just 4-foot walls maximum.
Someone wants to go in their backyard and build a kind of a rock wall
in their backyard, as long as it's 4-foot tall and no surcharge
on the top, that's perfectly fine. No permit required.
The city would still look at it, obviously, but no building permit required for
that. And the
one thing we would look at is surcharging. You know, are we parking cars on
top of this? Is it being built up for a parking pad or an RV
pad? Is a building or a shed or something
going to be on top of it? Those are the kind of things that you
would see in a surcharge situation. And then the other
thing you'd look at for surcharges is the Is there
a slope on top of the wall that comes up to the top of the
wall, and is it flat or is it actually sloped? Because if it's sloped,
then there's actually more loading on that because of the slope.
So those are the things we looked at, and this is kind of the way
we defined our two walls.
So this was the main complaint from the the building inspectors: is
it wasn't clear when actual building. Permit was
needed and when it was not. And so we tried to clarify this
in saying, you know, the gravity walls, 4-foot, no surcharge,
then no building permit. If it's above 4-foot
or if it has any kind of surcharge, no matter what the height,
it would definitely need a building permit to go
forward with that. So we tried to fix that little issue
Height standards. Like I mentioned before, 6 foot was,
was really the max for any type of wall height.
What we have proposed in this is that in residential properties, keep that same
6 foot height. I think that's reasonable for most residential properties.
And then in the commercial industrial areas where they have bigger
buildings and bigger parking lots that need more flat area,
move that up to 10 foot to allow them to flatten things
out and to use their property.
And then obviously that 10 foot is clearly in the building permit
range, and it's also in the range where we would look at
it really close on an engineering standpoint.
Multiple tiers. of retaining walls.
This was in the previous code, but the tier length
between the walls was 1.5 times the height.
We propose to change that, and this came from the building inspector's request
that that is changed to 2 to 1. So if
you have a 6-foot wall, it's 12 foot before you can actually put another retaining
wall. And that actually corresponds with the
International Building Code, and so we're actually just kind of mirroring What
the International Building Code, or IBC, says on that one.
And then, if for some reason it has to be less than
that, if there's constraints in the property, then it has to be built
and designed as a single wall system.
And in engineering terms, it basically means they have to do
the geotech for both walls, looking at them both not independently as different
walls, but as one wall system.
So, as part of that, and actually this applies not
just to the tiers, but to everything, we better defined exactly
what was submitted to the engineering department and to planning
as far as engineering requirements.
In the old code, it basically had to be stamped by a professional
engineer, and we kind of relied on that stamp.
Now we're actually going to be reviewing a lot
more information— lateral pressure, seismic loading,
the drainage, bearing capacity, those kind of things— so that we're looking
specifically at each wall, because each wall is, is going to be a little bit
different. And so we want to look at the calculations behind
where they got to and just make sure that we agree with those things before
we're approving those on an engineering basis. Thank you.
And then I mentioned this one, inspection requirements.
The previous code didn't have any inspection requirements, and this defines—
there's a list of multiple inspections in there.
We don't necessarily have to do every single inspection that's listed
in there, but it says we can, and it really allows our building inspectors to
be able to go out and check they need to check and, and look at
the things that they want to look at as these things are getting built.
Um, the one exception to that
is the mechanically stabilized earth walls.
Those walls, um, they're the walls that you
see UDOT put up when they're building a roadway way, way up
above, and, and they're 20, 30-foot tall walls, and it's— it looks like concrete panel
paneling is what it looks like. But those panels are anchored back into the soil,
and so the soil behind it is really what, what is holding that wall
up. And that's— it's very critical to get proper materials,
proper compaction, and those kind of things. And so that's why we said on those
walls, we, we want to— we will require
inspections on those, and we want to see the tests on the compaction
and those kind of things, just so we're We're making sure those are being built
in a safe manner.
And then property line and easement standards.
The old standard was the wall, the face of the wall had to be 3
feet from a property line. And we're actually saying, yeah,
we kind of agree with that because it clearly defines on whose
property that wall is. And if there's an issue with it, it's clearly
defined who needs to deal with it or address it. Where if it's right on
the property line, I think that's where this code originated from. If it's right
on the property line and there's an issue with it, then you have the 2
neighbors arguing over whose wall it is and who built it and
those kind of things. And so I think to avoid that, that's where this code
originated from. And we propose that
we keep that language in here. Now, we did add some
language. If you have a retaining wall, like on the back of a property that's
going on multiple lots, there's no reason to
do a small retaining wall and then stop, and then have another retaining wall in
the next lot and stop, and have another. We can have a continuous
retaining wall across all of those. But in that case,
it's typically built by the developer, and he's building
it as one cohesive. coherent or one cohesive system.
And so we would be looking at that as the developer comes in and
comes in for approval and those kind of things. But we said that that
is allowable to go across property lines
in a perpendicular manner.
Vince? Yes. With that, it talks about how if all owners
agree At that point when it's being approved and
whatnot by the city to a developer, really probably only
has one owner at that point. Are we looking to get some
future owner information, or is there going to be some sort of
disclosure in like the real estate documents?
Like, or is it just better
than it used to be? Right, right. We didn't
define that in this because we were mostly just looking at the technical side.
But yeah, I think what we were thinking is if you come
in after the fact, 2 neighbors want to put in one retaining wall and
they're separate owners. If it comes in as a developer,
I think it's the same owner and they can still put it in how they
want. Okay, thank you.
Yep. The other change that we had was the The PUE that
is on the back side of most lots, or even on the side
of most of our lots in the city, that public utility
easement has some restrictions. And in the old code, it said
we couldn't have any kind of retaining wall on the PUE, which was
actually a conflict with the 3-foot rule because most of our PUEs are either 5-foot
or 10-foot offset from that property line. So with
that one, we basically modified it to be similar to if someone
comes in and wants to put a sign in our PUE,
they have to come to us for an exception. It has to be looked at
and approved, but we would allow retaining walls in that PUE now with
the new code.
So yeah, that's really a summary of all the changes we made to
the code. Open it up for any questions you guys
have.
I don't really have a question, maybe just a comment, Vince. I mean,
great job, number one. Thank you for taking an engineer's look
at this. I think it's actually really well done.
My only concern is with 5B, and I just I,
I, I don't think we should leave multifamily properties in the, in the approved
for a 10-foot wall height because I think that just encourages hillside development,
which I want to stay away from anyway. So that would be my only comment,
that, and that's something I'd ask the council to do is consider removing the word
multifamily from 5B. Obviously we have
a public hearing and, and, and other things, so I don't really have any other
questions. That, that's my only comment. Just my, my question being, So the 3-foot
wall face, does it really have to be 3 feet to make sure people know
whose wall it is? Can we make it a little sooner, closer? That's what he
changed. No, I think he said that's what it was. Yeah, it's still 3
feet from the property line. Yeah, but the footing is 1 foot. It's 1 foot
for the footing. So you're 1 foot from the footing from the property line,
and then you're the center of the wall. So if you have a 2-foot,
I guess it's a little further away than that. It just depends how big the
footing is. Right, right. And it doesn't necessarily have to be
three foot, but it would have a footing on the wall. So if you're
on the lower side of that, even though the face of
the wall is three foot, or maybe it would be close, take care of it.
If if it's built right on the property line, now you're in your neighbor's yard
taking care of it if you need to. So for me, that makes complete sense.
The other question I had was. Maybe I missed
it, but I think it's 6B. When you're talking— or
is it C? 6A or C?
When you're talking about tiered walls, so the base wall and then the second
wall that's tiered back. Yep. There's no definition, at least I couldn't—
you have the length, but is there that gap that you're asking for? It doesn't
say how much. Twice the width. 12 feet? I mean,
you can have— if you have So if you go 4 feet and you go
back 2 feet and go another 4? Right, then it's considered a
single wall. Yep. So yeah.
So then my question is, even on the industrial
at 10 feet, I used to build a lot of these, and whether it's
block or whatever, at some point on anything over 6 feet,
they'd have to have a mesh or an engineered
Yeah, kind of an anchor system. Anchor. Yeah, I'm sorry. That would also
get buried behind that wall to keep the middle of the wall from bulging out.
Sure. So is that also— if
we're going to go to 10 feet, I'm just curious if that's something that we
need to, especially if it's load-bearing. Yeah,
that is something we would look at in our engineering review. We didn't spell that
out specifically in the code, but in the It requires a permit.
Yeah, it requires a permit, and it requires submittals of all
the calculations. And so as part of those calculation checks, we would
look at that. Does it need to be anchored to have stability? Do you think
that the code would protect us a little bit knowing that anything over 6 feet
is going to most likely require that, that we should
at least say something like that? Right. I think
with our engineering check, we could check and verify those
things as they come in. We could add it to the code explicitly if
you want, but I think it's— Is there any— is there
ever a time when you're going over 6 feet and we're talking about 10 feet
that you wouldn't require it? Yes, it would depend on the type of
the wall that they're building. Like a thick concrete wall with a big footing on
it wouldn't necessarily have to have anchors on it.
So yeah, it's a solid wall. If it's a solid wall.
Correct, correct. Solid wall.
Yep. If you feel comfortable. Okay, so is there any other questions
for Vince? We do have a public hearing, so nothing there.
All right, thank you. Um,
with that, it is 7:58 and this is
a public hearing, so I will open the public hearing and ask Lacey
if anyone— nobody turned in anything. Is there anyone
here that would like to speak on this item that did not get the opportunity?
Seeing no one, at 7:58, we will close the public hearing
and bring it back to the council for further discussion. I'll make a motion unless
there's concerns. Anybody have anything they want to add before
we do that? Melissa? I just— I want to say this. I'm really grateful
that we're doing this. I think that engineering and staff did a really great
job in preparing this code. But some of them are contingent
on whoever is working in the department at the
time and what inspections
and things that they're going to require. I want us to always make sure
that the culture of our city is that we require the
inspections and the engineering plans and all of those things because there are places in
our city where this hasn't been done, and I want
to make sure that that doesn't change. as we have different staff members over
the years. So I think I'm calling on our Building and Engineering
and Community Development Department to just really make sure that we
make these inspections and permits
our goal and our culture in our city. Thank you.
Entertain a motion, Mayor. I move that the Eagle Mountain
City Council approve an ordinance amending the municipal code
to repeal and replace Section 17.60.130 regarding
retaining wall construction standards with the change
of removing the multifamily, the word multifamily
from item 5B. Second.
Okay, we have a motion and a second. The motion by Councilmember Wright and a
second by Councilmember Whiting. Do we— sorry, go ahead.
Do we need to have Can we have them move or in front
of institutional, or is that inherent for staff
to be able to make that change? I'll amend my motion to include the word
or. Thank you. Second. Okay,
is there any other questions on the motion? The, uh,
motion stands with Councilmember Wright and a second by Councilmember Whiting, and we'll start the
vote with Councilmember Wright. Yes. Councilmember Whiting. Yes. Councilmember Huish? Yes.
And Councilmember Clark? Yes. Okay,
that item passes, and we will move to item 5B.
This is a— or sorry,
15B, you're right. An ordinance of Eagle Mountain
City rezoning certain lands known as the Pinnacles, approving the Pinnacles Master Development
Plan and Master Development Agreement Amendment.
And I believe Robert is ready. Good evening,
Mayor and Council. At the heart of this particular matter is simply a
request to rezone 3 parcels, properties of
land, aggregated about 14 acres— sorry for the typo in
the report— from their commercial neighborhood setting or zoning
to agriculture. This is based on a request, of course, by an applicant
representing that they have an interest in temporarily making this happen
to effectively save money on their tax bill, understandably so.
The zoning assigned to the project which
you see on the screen before you as far as location.
That's the Pinnacles, which is over north of Aviator and west
of Pony Express. Was something that was inculcated into a development
agreement memorialized back in the fall of 2022. At that
time, the Pinnacles set aside the properties that you see on your screen for,
again, commercial neighborhood, with the balance of the project into some form of
residential a different kind of commercial up at the top, if you will, and then
off to the west or to the left of the image, area for townhouses,
which has been already reviewed and approved.
As part of this action, if council's favorable with the idea,
by association you have also the
requirement, of course, to amend your future land use map so that
it harmonizes with the new zoning. And then because this was made part—
this whole affair was made part of a development agreement set with the master development
plan, those 2 items also need to be amended. But mainly it's housekeeping. It's just
simply saying we're okay with this new zoning here,
this ag zoning, and therefore we're going to amend the master development plan and
agreement, especially paragraph 3.2, and then our future land use
map to all fall in line with that decision.
Any questions? So is the motivation
for this is to save money on property tax? Yes, and there was some discussion
at the Planning Commission, who by the way advanced a favorable recommendation on this request,
as to whether that was going to happen with the zoning of
the property being changed. And their understanding that everyone walked
away with was basically, yes, we think that will happen. And the applicant explained the
why for and how for of that. So assuming they're here tonight, And they can
also go into detail on that matter if you'd like them to.
And we haven't had any contact from outside parties or communications, whether by phone
or email or visitation, that have discussed this matter with us other than just the
That's it.
No questions for staff?
Just making sure there is public hearing, so I can go to that if you're
okay. We'll go
ahead and hold the public hearing. It is 8:04, and we'll open
the public hearing and ask Lacey if she's seen anybody come forward.
No one. Okay. Is there anyone here who wants to speak on this
item? Seeing no one,
I will close the public hearing at 8:04 and bring it back to the council.
I do know the applicant. The applicant is
here, and is there any questions for
the applicant? Anything?
Any discussion? Anything? I'll share some thoughts.
I mean, let me just share some thoughts. I'm opposed to this,
to granting this, and certainly not with any desire
or willingness to be punitive towards an applicant that wants to reduce their taxes.
So let me state that publicly for you, Andy, so that you hear that.
That's not the reason that I'm opposed to this.
This was part of an MDP, it was part of an MDA, it was part
of a negotiation to develop this entire area,
which included giving some multifamily densities in this area.
And the tradeoff, at least in my mind, was that we were going to ensure
that there's some commercial development that comes in there along Aviator. I think by choosing
to move this back to Ag, what we do in a sense is we reset
the table and we say, come back and petition
a future council to do whatever you'd like. You can still do that with the
neighborhood commercial resident designation, zoning designation.
It's just it requires the council to then understand
the context of where it's been and why.
So at least for So for me, that's where I'm feeling some hesitancy to
want to do this because of that.
So— Sorry, I was just— Marcus, I just can't remember
on— as far as greenbelt exemptions,
you can get greenbelt in any zone, right? So even commercial zone could get a
greenbelt or an ag exemption as long as there's an agricultural
use, right? So plant a cherry tree,
harvest Sell a cherry.
It's been a minute since I've looked at that code. I think it has to
be ag-zoned or something similar to that. So I don't think you can greenbelt.
I know. But I'm not 100% certain on that without researching.
Residential qualifies for greenbelt, right? So I'd have
to look at that. I don't know if this is 5 acres or more.
I don't know how— Right. If it's 5 acres or more, which I don't remember
the property. Yeah, it's plenty over 5. Plenty over 5,
okay. Yeah, so I'd have to look at that. I'm not certain. Just a
thought that there could be some tax savings if there was an avenue
to go. Go ahead, Greg. I think going
back to Council Member Wright's point, I think that this was part of a larger
negotiation with some give and take, and one of those,
and it landed upon this particular grouping of approvals.
And so it's sort of, it was taken as a whole when it
was approved. I will say that when it
came previously, it was way more dense,
like the property to the east, and the
council at the time was the one that was pushing to have
additional commercial right there. So like, I feel like
that was an ask of people from our city. As opposed
to the developer per se. So I'm— I get why they
would like to reset that piece for tax purposes and really determine
viability down the road so that when it does come back,
a future council can look at what the best use of it is.
I do understand the hesitancy because what
it does is it puts the responsibility on a future council. To do their homework
and really understand what's going on with that piece. But I would hope that our
staff reports have come such a long way from what they used to be that
they could provide that context in the staff report and
even older documents to show what it once was.
But am I allowed to make a comment here? Yeah, I'll let you speak.
Zap can address the concern. All right, thank you. This is— my name is Andy
Flamm. I represent represent the property owners. I just
wanted to say, when this first was negotiated, or I
guess that's the right word, negotiated and contemplated with the city, it happened over several
years. And one of the concerns was 800 North in
Orem. There's a lot of traffic on
800 North, and there's a lot of old homes that are having to get purchased
and redeveloped. And forward thinking,
This was determined in meetings with the Planning Commission and
staff and others that we wanted to preserve some commercial
corridor right here in anticipation of a future freeway.
I don't know when that will be, but it was a good idea and I
supported it and I thought it was a great compromise.
I still do. The development agreement— this was actually approved in the
fall of '21. So the development agreement actually expires
next year, if I remember right. But so we
would have to come back if we rezoned this property to
anything else in the future, and that development agreement probably
wouldn't even apply at that time anyway. But the reason
why I'm here trying to rezone it back to ag, which is something you probably
rarely see, is when we put
in— Never. Never. When the roads were put in,
when we had to detain— retain water on our site for Aviator,
we lost our greenbelt status and we're getting killed. And to
get it back in, we're told that we need to get it in ag,
and we're working with some leases to get it back in because right now we've
had this thing on the market for a year and a half. We've talked
to a lot of people. There's no demand for
commercial on a dead-end road at this time. Now, there will be, and we
believe in that vision of having this be commercial in the future.
But until then, we're just getting killed on taxes.
And I know that's been a hot topic, but when you actually look
at taxes in general, property taxes, but when you
look at what actually goes to the city from this site, and most
of it's going to the county or the school district or whatnot. Our application
fee tonight to even just do this rezone
probably put the city ahead already.
So again, we were trying to be— or we were,
I felt like, a good partner when we brought this project forward. There was a
lot of discussion and what the city wants, and we were Again,
we're not asking to change to high-density residential,
which I've been in so many meetings in here where an applicant comes back
and says, we tried for a year. Well, this is 6 years in and there's
still no demand for commercial. And so anyway,
that's the ask. I just wanted to give a little bit more context to it
just because I know there's some new faces from when this originally came
forward. But any other questions for me? from the council or the mayor?
Go ahead. Yeah, sorry, I looked at the Act and I mean,
so technically you could get greenbelt status in a commercial zone,
but it's not a permitted use. So, and it sounds
like if they lost greenbelt status, it's because they're not engaging in Act uses,
which means there's no nonconforming use.
So they couldn't get greenbelt status in a commercial zone
because it would be a nonconforming use. Unless we made
some kind of exception or— Well, no, I mean, they're asking to rezone it.
So then they obviously— ag would be a permitted use. They could get their greenbelt
status back. We've got the rest of the property fenced and we've got leases.
And this— it was a dry farm historically, but when
they came in and they had a grade to put in the retention ponds on
the 3 different parcels, County just happened
to come out right when that was all graded, and so anyway, we didn't have
the new crop out, and we lost that status. So anyway, another question that
I wonder if we'd consider is the future land use map
would, with an expired MDA,
as long as it was on the future land use map as neighborhood
commercial, would that guide a council to that? And then could
you write a one-page Agreement would extend it at least six
years on this piece. It says that it's intended to be,
you know, because it's going to expire anyway. I mean, all that's
a possibility. Totally supportive of keeping the the land use
map with commercial. We're not intending to change that. That's that's
not what this is about. No, and you know, and my my concern
again, I'll just restate it. This is a perfect place for someone to
come back in if it's rezoned. Zone to ag and ask to build multifamily housing
in this area. And for me, it's just— that's a nonstarter.
It's intended to be commercial. I understand that perhaps the viability
of that is not today. But we had this
conversation, at least I wasn't here at the time, so it predates me.
2021, I wasn't here. I think you were at
Planning Commission maybe at the time. I was on Planning Commission at that time.
And so Look, I've stated my objection.
The others may feel differently than that. That's where I'm going to land.
Um, Councilmember Wright, do you feel like the land use designation on the future
land use map helps to kind of set the vision for this area?
Because we have lots of areas that we as a city have
returned to ag because we wanted that to be like the base level,
and then they have to come and ask for something different. Do I— and
the reason for that, at least in my mind, is because we wanted to reset
that so that it would come to something that we want rather than what it
was. Okay. And for me, commercial makes sense here. It's just—
and it already has that designation, and it's part of a larger agreement.
I think that's the— for me, at least, the hurdle that I'm not able to
get over. What about the expiration of the larger agreement? Because that is something that
went into place when you were on Planning, and I was— the MDA
will expire in 6 years, right? We want those things to reset,
and it's really a question of what does this council want? Does this council want
to see this maintained as a, as a commercial area, or do we want to
reset it to, to ag? I've stated my objection to it.
The rest of you can do what you want. Okay, thank you.
So even if, even if the future land use map shows commercial, you still feel
like that there's That they're— There's nothing on the
future land use map that dictates that it's going to happen. The zoning requires this
to be commercial now. That's the difference in my mind.
It's no different than what we dealt with on the north end of the city
where we have these mixed uses and it says, we'll try to pursue commercial
uses in this area and it always ends up residential. For me, it's protecting
some of those commercial uses in an area that I think we're going to want
and need it. We had an applicant who came before
us and wanted to build a 12-plex on that commercial lot where Freddy's is at
now. So I think it's the same argument that I've seen
time and time again. It's the same movie.
I'll make a motion, Mayor, if you want, and, and then we'll find
out where the rest of these guys are at. How does that sound? Do it.
If you're willing to let me do that, let me get I got to open
it up here. OK. I have it here.
I've got it. Mayor, I move that the Eagle Mountain City Council
deny the reason— the item— what is it? 15B,
rezoning certain lands known as Pinnacles and approving the Pinnacles Master
Plan, Master Development Plan, and Master Development Agreement Amendment.
Second. Okay,
we have a motion by Councilmember Wright and a second by Councilmember Whiting.
And I think we were here. Councilmember Whiting? Yes.
Councilmember Hewish? Yes. Councilmember Clark? No.
Councilmember Wright? Yes. Okay, that passes 3-1.
Uh, thank you. Let's see, that takes us
to item 16A, uh, an ordinance of Eagle Mountain City enacting
Chapter 3.50 of Eagle Mountain Municipal
Code establishing property tax allocations.
Actually, before I move on, I don't think this was a big
deal, but I— when there's one vote, did you want to make any— do
I need to stop or— Oh, I think
it really just comes down to the fact that I think that it is a
good move to reset that land with the expectation
that it's commercial because it's in our future land use
map. And I remember the ask was something that the city asked the landowner of,
so that's why I just felt like it, it made sense to
approve it. But I respect everyone else's right to make their
choices too. Yep. I just— before, I like
everybody to have a chance to explain if they choose. So, uh, yeah,
it's, uh, enacting Chapter 3.15 or 3.50 of the
Eagle Mountain Municipal Code establishing property tax allocations.
Um, I, uh, Evan's got some information,
so. Yes,
uh, Mayor and Council, we'll run through this code just to kind of COVID
what's, uh, changed since the last time we talked about it and, uh,
answer any remaining questions. And I will say right off the bat
that, uh, this is definitely not a perfect code. Uh, it's something that
we haven't had before, as was mentioned, And it's the best shot
we're giving it right now. But I expect there'll be some kinks in it that
we'll probably have to work out later as we go through this process. So we'll
work on this together over the next budget season and see how it goes
and modify as needed. But we tried to cover everything we could with it.
So as you recall, the instructions that we received from the council
is to draft this code. That would essentially allocate the
property taxes, all the property taxes that we receive to
public safety into a public safety fund that would be restricted
for those uses. And then it would establish certain coverage
ratios that we'd then be monitoring from year to year to make sure that where
we need to reduce property taxes 'cause we're collecting too much, we do that.
Where we need to increase property taxes 'cause we don't have enough, we do that.
But then throughout the course of the year, we're also keeping tab on the certain
metrics and, you know, different analysis to make sure that we have a good handle
on where our public safety needs are and that we are tracking
this effectively and transparently for the public
so that this is working as intended. So just to break
it down a little bit for you, and I'll just run through this fairly
quickly, the first couple of pages They go through
the purpose and the general policy, and so you have just essentially
breaking down that what we just said. This is, you know,
for property tax to go into this public safety fund.
But I want to call attention to a couple of things in here.
First, there was, you know, commentary made last time
just about how do we make sure that this this code isn't
just something that we just have, and it's not. I don't want to use the
word necessarily enforced, but we talk about accountability, trying to make sure that it's something
that we are sticking to, that we're not just kind of loosely
adhering to. And so I was trying to come up with some
method that we could do that, some sort of pressure that it puts both on
council and staff to make sure that we
move forward with this vision, but it's also not
too heavily impactful that we start kicking ourselves because
of how we're doing this. And so what I came up with for now
is that essentially we're creating an order of operations
with things wherein we're forcing
the conversation of the public safety side to come earlier or
as early as possible in this, where obviously we know as a
growing city, one of the most important things that we have to monitor is our
own staffing levels citywide. And so we know
there's going to be questions every year about how much staff that we can allocate
for all sorts of city services. But when we're talking
about property tax as kind of that key revenue source that's going to fund public
safety, and with this coverage ratio, knowing that that coverage
ratio may require more sales tax or less sales tax from
year to year, we need to settle that core public service
that we offer as a city, um, first and then talk about the
other staffing stuff later. And when I say later, it's not that finance
can't necessarily start gathering some of that information, start getting
some of that feedback so that we can continue the process as quickly as it
needs to go, but no decisions necessarily by the city council
or their staff will happen with the other staff until the
public safety fund and everything like that has been figured out. If that, hopefully that
makes sense. I also wanted to just
call out an attention, just there's obviously on page 2, there's some definitions.
One of the ones that's another change
that I didn't really notate specific on here is that there's a definition
for qualified public safety costs. I added in
there that some language that makes it clear that facilities falls
under that as well. So we can make sure that we're— we do
have a public safety impact fund already, impact fee fund,
but if there's other revenues we could pull off property tax to help pay debt
service and other things for public safety facilities, then that's worked in
there as well. Um,
on pages 3 and 4 talks about the creation of that public safety fund.
I did eliminate a sentence that as I went,
so there is specific state code that talks about the creation of funds
for property tax dollars. And so there was
a line that we had in there that I felt like ran contrary to
what state code has in there. It doesn't make any meaningful change to
the code itself that we have in here. So this is just more of a
cleanup item. The rest of that,
there's some stipulations about making sure that the funds can't
just be transferred to and fro for whatever reasons. It needs to stay in the
public safety fund for those public safety purposes.
The coverage ratio evaluations added some
language in there about making
sure that we're collecting some level of service metrics, and those level of service metrics
are gonna be what helps us determine what
is that public safety funding requirement We're not just throwing
out feel-good numbers of how many sheriff's deputies or whatnot
that we need. It has to be supported by evidence.
Pages 5 and 6 goes into additional guidance
on the fund balance, how we handle when we have an increasing or decreasing
fund balance, how do we handle other cost allocations,
which is mostly relevant if the city chooses at
some point to establish its own independent police department will wanna handle things like
HR costs and IT costs and risk management and things like that that
often fall in other departments but then have to get transferred to and from.
And then there's the annual reporting side of things.
And with the annual reporting, I did add a
section in there about making sure that annual reporting or
an annual summary makes it to the public. Earlier in the process
so that it's not something where the public's only finding out about it at the
tail end of the budgeting process. That just as much as you are
also receiving that information about the public safety fund
and the public safety needs in our city, the public is also learning about that
through this, you know, similar metrics and things like that and receiving it in
multiple formats.
Besides that, I do want to pass some time to Kimberly.
We talked about this a fair bit and just wanted to give
her some time to kind of talk a little bit about her thoughts
on just how to implement this. And then just some things that would help if
you guys can work together on making sure that the process keeps
moving smoothly as we go through this. So.
So, Mayor and Council, a couple of items just to
kind of keep in mind with this particular code.
So one of the items is the special revenue
fund that we're creating. It will be created from a budgetary purpose,
so it it'll work similar to the way that we have
our water and sewer impact fees. So the water
and sewer Sewer impact fees we separate from a budgetary standpoint,
but in the year-end financial statements those are actually just part of the water fund
and the sewer fund because you can't have a special revenue fund for non-government
activities. Okay, so this there's some accounting
provisions where it's like state code we can do certain things,
but when it comes to the financial statements for accounting, this won't
meet the requirements for an like a separate special revenue fund. So that's
all on our books and the things that we're doing. You'll see it as a
separate fund. We'll budget it separately. But in the year-end financial statements,
it will be grouped up as part of the general fund.
So I just want to make sure that that part is clear.
Then that when we talk about trying
to ensure that decisions have
been made kind of about the funding for public safety before we
make decisions on other things. What those decisions that
we're talking about from the council's perspective is how
much revenue do we need to be able to generate from a property
tax standpoint compared to other revenue resources
in relation to funding public safety with the understanding
that we won't actually receive a certified tax rate until June,
which is way past when we have a tentative budget that has to come to
the council. So when we're talking about making these
decisions for the planning and moving things forward, it's not
something that can wait until the certified tax rate is available.
So in Utah, when we're talking about taxes, it really doesn't have anything
to do with the rate. The rate is just what happens based
on the revenue you decide that you need. Thank you. And that is how
it's designed to work. So it will be looking
at that and that we will have projections from
that. And it doesn't prevent you when it gets to the end and you get
your certified rate and the revenue you thought you were going to get would
be looking at truth in taxation. It means that we want
to get mentally at the perspective of is the council is considering truth in taxation
every year. It doesn't mean you end up having to go through Truth in Taxation.
Your decision is how much tax revenue do you need
to fund this part of the service. So in terms of the
order and the timeline of things, I want to make sure we have a chance
to talk about that and what that looks like.
Do you have any questions kind of about what I'm, you know,
kind of trying to cover from that perspective?
So just so we're all on the same page,
this is kind of what I hoped we would have had earlier in
the year. Uh, I think our coverage ratio was 32% or
35% going into this whole conversation, and we started
out, let's go 100% coverage, and now we've kind of dialed it
back. I think we'll be at 52% with— for this
year. So going into next year, as we're having conversations
with Chief Knutson and staffing and going through those metrics,
um, is it possible for us to kind of anticipate
what that revenue might look like from a property tax perspective and
match that up? Like, that, that, that's really the goal, is just
that right out of the gate we're looking at the coverage ratio, we're looking at
that number one. And Chief Knudson is going to, um,
you know, seeing what we've just kind of went through as a city He's
going to be probably pretty measured in, okay, this is the ask, and as a
council, we're going to say this is safety,
and residents now will know that every dollar they're
paying in property tax goes into the safety fund. So I just
want to make sure that we're logistically going to be able to do that,
understanding that the certified tax rate won't really be established until
later, later in the process, but we'll at least know going into that.
If we need to increase a little bit to get another half
a million dollars or decrease because the data center
property tax has taken us way over what the need is for sheriffs, you know,
and we might need to dial that back a little bit. Right.
So it's tying these 2 policies together. The policy
where you said what is the coverage ratio that you want to cover,
and if you're trying to target a minimum of 75% to
that, then that really is where you are coming up
with this is what the existing contract is, and then
we start considering asks or what those staffing needs are,
and then being able to say to cover 75% of that, we are talking revenue
at least at this number.
You agree that is all possible early in the budget process? Absolutely. possible early
in the budget. Yeah. What it can't be or has to happen
is very early on in the budget you have to say regardless we don't
care about the 75% policy, we don't want to consider tax,
truth in taxation at all this year, right. So you're either
using the policy to drive you, it's not, you're not deciding
whether you're doing truth in taxation. You're deciding whether you're following your policy
and the certified tax rate when it comes in The revenue you said you
needed, it either falls within that line or it just means you now have
these public hearings that you do. Or, Kimberly,
perhaps there's something that you know is coming online that
isn't in the diagnostic or in the report so
that you can look at that and say, okay, we are 3 months from this
becoming a reality, right? I like this,
Councilmember Herwish, because it creates an accountability for
council members to be aware of that metrics.
And I mean, I've been here a number of years and this is the first
time I've ever really looked at it from that lens. And that's why I'm grateful
to Councilmember Hewish for kind of pushing me in that
direction to examine it. And I, I also,
I'm going to say this, it's kind of a moving target. That's what you're saying
is it's a moving target. And, and we might think it's X, But it really
is going to be Y, and it can be up or it can be down,
right? Usually it goes up, doesn't usually
go down, or it's just flat. So,
but I like that it compels us to evaluate that and to say, okay,
we're still in a good range, or boy, we're way out of whack on our
range. We need to talk about how do we, how do we fill the gap.
The other thing that it— I'm just thinking about incentive
structures as a council. We're going to want more commercial. Because we know when we
add more rooftops, we need more sheriffs, more cost.
Truth in taxation, that's not fun. At least I didn't think it
was very much fun. Commercial actually brings more calls for service
than residential, though. Well, I guess depending on the commercial, right?
Like the data centers probably aren't getting too many calls. Correct.
So I have a clarifying question, and I know you and I have talked about
this a few times, and sometimes we don't always say things the same way,
so I'm going to make sure that staff and you are on the same page.
Because you said things like, this is a public safety fund.
I want to identify that. And then you said we only covered it at 32%.
Knowing where we're headed, is this only for
the sheriffs to evaluate, or is it all? Because we are way over 32% if
it's for both. So I think it's unfair to say— Yep. Okay,
okay. So, so I want to make sure that now we're bringing in next Yes,
so is this public safety fund? You're not even necessarily bringing in that.
We already have a public safety division that
includes more than just the contract, right? We have dispatch fees that we pay.
We have emergency management services. So yes,
that's a clarification. Is this only the
sheriffs? We have school crossings. Or is this public safety?
School crossing guards. We're talking police and fire. Like, are we trying to meet 75%
of what? What? And 32% is not the
correct number because we're paying more than that now out of property tax because it's
100% covered for the, for fire out of property tax currently.
Well, now you're bringing in fire, which will be— is it
part of this fund or not? It would be, yeah. I mean, I don't know
that it's drafted that way today, but next year
we could amend the code to include fire. Right now it's just specifically the sheriff's
contract. But next year— It's both. It's public safety.
That's what I'm asking.
The code as it's written right now specifies police services.
Even though it says public safety fund, it is written right
now as police services, but with the idea in mind that it could be amended
next year to then keep the title as public safety,
but then change the the scope to include fire.
So why don't we just write it for both now? Is the intent not to
be for both? Well, because we just don't have fire today, but we
could amend it. It can still— even if we're paying 100%
of fire and 50% of— that's still an 85% coverage out of property tax.
If it's legal to put that in the code, I'd be okay with that.
They're both contracts. What's the difference?
That's up to you. That's why I was asking. I think— I mean, it's Yeah,
I agree. I think we were just focused more on the sheriff's contract, and then
next year, once we actually have fire announced,
then we amend the code to include— Would you be okay to just do public
safety? Oh, I think absolutely. There's no reason to bring this back. Yeah, I think
the only issue would just come to, you know, when we're talking about staffing
and coverage and things like that, we obviously just can't talk about that really
until we know what with UFA once we actually have that under
a contract. Property taxes are covering that. I think it's unfair to say that 100
plus 85, that's more than— I think that's more than what
I— that's my opinion. That's an opinion. That's not— Yeah, I think the weighted
average of where we landed with the sheriff's contract, the 69%
increase and 100 of UFSA, when you do the weighted average,
it's like 77. 86%. Which is why I say it still falls within that.
It would, it would, yep. So we don't need 85% of
just the sheriffs, we need 85% of all public safety? Correct.
Regardless of whether we're in-house or through UFSA?
Correct. Is that, is that clear?
Can I— let me state this, Mayor, because I mean, I think we're going
to have these discussions as we enter into that UFSA discussion.
And so from my perspective, This gives us the
tools to evaluate all public safety and to say, are we in that percentage?
I think it should probably relate to the whole thing, Councilman Pewisch. It sounds like
you agree. And if that's the case, I think
that will help give us a guide too for next year to what
do we do with that rate associated with UFSA. It'll,
it'll give us a guideline to land where we really want to be.
My only question would be, what is the timing on UFSA?
The UFA? So the, the conversation,
and it's been really, uh, with referendums and different
things, it's been a, a little bit harder to nail that down. But we
gave the notice to withdraw. The problem is,
is the taxing, moving that tax over and timing of who collects
the tax. So right now what we've decided is that
we would leave or exit
UfSA July 1st, 2028.
Sorry, July— January 1st, 2028. Then next year,
so 2027 budget year, just like this year, one year from what we just did,
we would do the Truth in Taxation process to— Establish the rate.
Establish the rate so that if for some reason we have
issues, then we couldn't get out because of the that
people want UFSA to keep charging too much, because that's still possible.
And otherwise, we'll be able to pull it in and people will see the wisdom
in that. If it passes, then we can exit. If we exit too early,
then nobody's taxing at all. And we still want fire coverage, right?
Yeah, we still want to. So, and I'm gonna— I think that
was the layman's term of saying the timing of how that works. And if
Marcus wants to clarify, you're welcome to. Was that a fair enough
assessment? Yeah, I mean,
that is my understanding is that they want it to be on January 1st of
whatever year we pull out. So yeah,
if we aren't able to raise our taxes to cover, that would be problematic for
funding it. So it does make sense to leave,
to stay in UFSA until we've pulled that, done that switch.
But let's be clear when we say if we're unable to raise our taxes,
If we raise those taxes, UFSA is going to lower their tax. I want our
residents to hear that. There's going to be a trade-off there. The net change would
be essentially zero in the first year and go down over time.
Or go down even the first year because of the difference in taxable value,
but we have to get through that. So then the second option that I've
already worked on with the state, and I know Evan and I have talked about
it, it's been a while, is creating legislation that when you have a special service
district, that we don't have to do the entire Truth in Taxation process,
because it is just changing where that tax and how it's getting paid for.
It's not an increase. Right. But I think that right now that we need
to work on that, because it's an increase for one and a decrease on the
other. I don't think that's an increase
overall. So that's something that we will, as they work on that 5%
rule, I've already talked to the bill sponsor from last year that
They've got to have a carve-out for special service districts, or how do you ever
leave? You'd be trapped forever and they could go wild. So that's, that's,
uh, why that timing.
I want to do it sooner, but because the public's done what the public's done,
then it's going to cost us another year of paying way too much to UFA—
UFSA. We love UFA, whoever.
So is it, is it easier— maybe
I'll just ask Evan and And Marcus's question, is it easier to pass it as
is stated right now? Just considering the Sheriff's Office, would it make more
sense for us to— I mean, I can make a motion and amend
it to include fire as well. I don't know how difficult that would be to
add that in. I think if we were to pass it today, I would prefer
to leave it as is. And if we were to change it to include fire,
I would table it and bring it back.
I don't think it's any easier or harder either way, to be honest, because either
way we have to make changes and bring it back, whether it's in 2 weeks
or whether it's in a year.
If I can make just one quick correction too.
If you choose, and I don't know which way you're going on this, If you
choose to, you know, move forward on the ordinance as is
tonight, just after talking with Kimberly, and I've caught
this myself too, is there's one word that we'd need to change in
the motion. So under 3.50.110,
it's at the very end of this code, B was
added. It says the annual summary must be shared with the public in a public
meeting prior to the adoption of the annual tenant It shouldn't say adoption, it should
say acceptance of the annual tentative budget.
So just want to make sure that is clear so that we don't get our
words mixed up as far as what that's supposed to be.
Which, which section was that? That was 3.50.
It's the very last section, 3.50.
What was the word change? From adoption to acceptance.
OK, adoption. Because when the City Council receives the
tentative budget, You're not adopting it, and in a budget you're accepting it. From adoption
to accept. Okay. Adoption to accept.
All right. I'll go ahead and make a motion then. Yeah.
Mayor. There was no public hearing, so if there's no
other discussion, I'm yeah. Okay. All right, Mayor. I'll make a motion that
the City of Eagle Mountain adopt an ordinance of
Eagle Mountain City, Utah, enacting Chapter.
3.50 of the Eagle Mountain Municipal Code establishing property
tax allocations with the change,
the change of the word adoption to acceptance in
Section 3.50.110.
Second. Okay, just clarification,
he moved to adopt the resolution or is it approve? Does that matter? We okay
with adopt? Um, I, I don't have
a preference for adopt or approve the ordinance. It's fine. Okay, when you approve—
do you want me to restate? I'll restate it. No, I just want to make
sure that adopt was okay. Oh, okay. If you're good with that. If he's good
with it, I am. What's your— did you have a question?
Okay, we're good. Uh, motion by Councilmember Hewish
and a second by Councilmember Whiting. Are there any other questions? I think we'll
start the vote with Councilmember Herch. Yes. Councilmember Clark. Yes.
Councilmember Wright. Yes. And Councilmember Whiting. Yes. Okay,
that passes. Thank you.
Appreciate the insight and the foresight on getting that thing
through. Yeah, so, all right, we have
just about wrapping up legislative priorities
list. I have one thing I want to add. And I spoke to Council Member
Wood today, and there was something that I said that's a good thing for this
list, and I forgot what it was. So if you remember— Can I, can I
add one thing, Mayor? Oh, are we going to let John do his magic first?
You're welcome to talk about it, and then you can follow. If you're ready,
go ahead. Yeah, right now we're working
on the legislative priorities for next season
as they're working through the legis— the interim session right now. So we haven't really
moved on your council priorities for the city stuff that I'm working on. I have
to reach out, reach back to everybody and see how they're doing with the other
part of the list. So not much to report other than that. And I
have met with, I think, all of you now regarding the list except
Melissa. So we're almost done with it.
Yes, she did say after— she did say after the 12th, after another meeting
we have So is
there anything that you need to add to the list? Yeah, I would like to
add something, John, and see how the council— see what the council's temperament is to
do this. We've had this discussion before, and I think there's going to be broad
support. But I'd like to put this on the list that we
do whatever it is we need to do to dedicate or to rename
the wildlife migration corridor
Migration Corridor as the Todd A. Black Memorial Wildlife Migration Corridor. I just
don't want to see that get lost. We're coming up on the 1-year anniversary of
his— of our losing him, and I just want to make
sure that we do that and we begin to refer to it in those terms.
If the council agrees with me, I agree with it. Do we need
to make a motion to add that or direct staff or something? So moved.
So seconded.
Okay,
so there's a motion by Councilmember
Wright and a second by Councilmember Clark to add to the priority list the name
change of the corridor. And we'll start the vote with Councilmember Clark.
Yes. Councilmember Wright. Yes. Councilmember Whiting. Yes. Councilmember Hewish.
Yes. And so that's— it's a great action, and I
don't mind it being on the list. I'm just trying to think if it sits
there for too long, If there's an easier way, I mean, this isn't
it's not code. This is just no, we just put it on the agenda.
Yeah, and my thought process is this, Mayor. Maybe we can erect some signs.
We can you know put them on some of the fencing that he erected.
Just something to recognize and name it, and then change it on our maps so
that doesn't just show up as the deer migration corridor or the wildlife corridor.
It shows up as the Todd A. Black Memorial Wildlife Corridor.
My point was is there's not a lot for. We just need it to come
on an agenda to change the— Whatever you want to do with it, Big John,
let's make it happen. So yeah, I'll put it on top of this. I have
till the 12th to meet with Melissa, so the other one can sit and wait
for a little bit. 13th. Actually, the 14th. The 12th is
a holiday. So that's— I know there was a couple other things that
we— oh, I want to— and I'll come to Councilmember
Clark, but for Councilmember For Hewish's sake, I don't know that I've heard,
but you brought up earlier the code for parking trailers.
We should probably get an update or whatever on that.
Go ahead, Councilmember Clark. Or do you have— Do
I have an update on it? Yeah, just for us to talk
about it. Is it on our list yet? We put it on the 4th.
I think it should be on the list. Okay, so it's
just a— Is it on the list? Follow-up. I'd have to check. I don't remember
seeing that. If I could jump in on this one. So it was put on
the list. It was created, a code was created.
It did go through Planning Commission and it did come to City Council and then
it was denied. So this would be an action to put it back on the
list if that's what we want to do. Well,
so it was denied prior to going back on the list.
Before the last election, when it was denied, correct? So then
it got back on the list. And so I think what we need to do
is—that's what I'm getting at—is I think we just bring the bring that code
back. Yes, because I don't think there's a ton of staff
work because we've already done the staff work. Yes. Do you do you want it
to come on as a work session discussion amongst the council first before running
it through planning commission and everything and doing noticing? Or do you want just to
start? I was. I think so, because the reason it was denied is it wasn't
ready. So there's obviously some talk, but— Maybe bring it back in
a working session and we can fine-tune that a little bit. I know I'm
new and there's been a lot of thought put into that previously,
but I think the issue still is persisting.
And initially this came up from residents
with support from staff. So we're behind
it. I think at the time that it came up, there was residents that were
in favor of it, and that's how it got onto the legislative priority list.
And then at the time it came back to the council, there was residents against
it, and for different reasons. And I don't question that at all.
It's just we're happy to— we serve with a pleasure. But I do think
that we already had— if we still have that, we had it written. It's just
a matter of bringing it back for discussion. So let's— if— I think that's
why, as far as the list, That's why I brought it up, is if we
just have Lacey pull that back up,
put it on our next work session, and we'll,
yeah, we'll just move forward. So that one will kind of give
you a little relief, 'cause I think we've got it. Councilmember Clark.
Okay. I shared some code for annual
budget metrics and budget in brief with,
it started as an email from Councilmember Hewish, to like me and a couple
staff members. So I don't know if John's on that email or not, but if
he's not, would someone please forward it to him? Um, I also am
grateful that we're going to be taking a look at the business licensing for home-based
business. One of the other things that has come up with different residents
is the, the idea of agritourism.
There have been applications, or at least questions about pumpkin
patch and just different things like that, or farm-to-table dinners,
or farm— like sourdough classes, and just different things like
that. So with the support of council, I would
like for us to consider adding agritourism code to
our legislative priorities
list, and hopefully economic development team can help kind of
guide that a little bit. And then the last one that
I wanted to check on is Justice Court. This got added to our
list, I want to say like February 2024.
Can I jump in on that? Yeah. I actually was, during our work session,
I was communicating with Chris Karn and Paul Binns about
this topic, and that's what it was that I said I couldn't remember. So in—
You're welcome. Yeah, thank you for— because I was like, I have to talk about
this. In Lehigh, they have somewhat canceled their Justice
Corps. And the council, it's been a— if you listen to their meetings, it's been
a little bit of a wrestle over there on the whole Justice
Corps. Mayor Binns called me and said, hey,
would you guys be interested in joining us and doing something different? Because this just
isn't working. I mentioned, you know, we've already been kind of looking at doing
something with Saratoga. Even if it's district or if it's municipal,
Saratoga thinks they pay way too much for for
what they have, and I don't want to say they hate
it, but it's it's it's expensive to
do it for just their city. So I mentioned that I would bring it up
tonight as I was trying to get through that, and and
I forgot. But there there's a great desire.
At least the 3 mayors that have talked about it, to either—
it can be municipal court, but 3 interlocal, and we could
house it. I believe— I haven't talked to Mark, obviously, but Chris isn't aware.
And, uh, we could house it at Saratoga. We could
do a separate building, you know, build a, you know, do, do a fund and
bond for its own court. But I'm just curious what the— because
of like what you're saying, we know that there's a need. The public wants Police
force, things like that. Do we want to— I, I think we
for sure should explore those options, and I get that
it's a pretty significant cost. Um, even before we
do that, I know that there's something that has
to be done with our code to enter it into some
sort of system so people can get ticketed for something.
So I'm saying that so Chief Knutson can tell us what that
is. So in the interim, while we're waiting for a justice court to get established,
we can do whatever it takes so that we can actually
start enforcing our laws. That's all I'm asking for is
enforcement. So, so it would be adding the bail schedule to— so
that our ordinances are within the ability for
the master offense table. Okay,
so moved. That's all I want, you guys. I want it done. So I think
by the end of this This one may be a little different because I don't
know that it's necessarily John's job. In my opinion,
I think I'd rather instruct Ben to work with Mark and Jason.
But can we get that to happen so we
can enforce our law? Well, if not, you've got the power to fire him.
I don't know, just tell him to do it. No,
I— to me, in a lot of ways, the legislative affairs person is It's
their role to pick up the football that we've laid out and run with it
until it's done. But I also think the relationships with our city managers is where
this is gonna happen. But I think the other
cities already have their stuff entered in, 'cause they already have their own police forces.
It's the disconnect within ours. Oh, we're talking about 2 different things. That's what I'm
talking about, yeah. We're talking about 2 different things, sorry. I apologize. You're talking about
the bell schedule. Yes. So yes, that is something that,
It's actually probably our fee schedules.
You can put it on the list, but it's going to fall under the
recorder's office or in the— I know Finn
was running with this one. We'll just have to figure out how we're going to
move forward with it. So that's a separate issue than what I was talking
about. Yes. So, but in the meantime,
that's what I'm saying. Yes, let's explore every option we can with
our neighboring cities. But the thing that's holding us back from enforcing
stuff is that master list and entering that into the system.
And I just want to make that happen by the end of this year,
please and thank you. So is there— is
there support on this one? This is something that's been on
the back burner for me just because I haven't had time to address it,
and that I was planning on assigning to the new attorney. So I'm
happy to assign that to whoever that person is. So is that better than the
priority list? Because I think— Is that something that we could hire or secure
the services of a contractor to do? Like, what does it entail?
Like, what are we looking at? Because— It's just reviewing the code,
finding, you know, everywhere where it's set where it creates a criminal offense.
And then you have to get the code, and then you have to create
language, charging language for them to put into the court
system. So it's working with the Administrative Office of the Courts to get
that into their system, so that, to the master
offense table, so that in their computer program, they can just pull it up.
It'll say, you know, Eagle Mountain Municipal Code or whatever, you know,
Section 6.05020, animal violations,
and then it'll have charging language, and it'll automatically
be able to reference that. Ben's gonna solve all my problems right now.
It would be able to have a dropdown box or whatever they have in their
computer program. So it's not something that I can— I'm aware
that there's actually a state law requiring it. It's just something that the
kind of the fickle nature of the AOC that they require it.
I've been through this once before. It is a fairly detailed
and tedious assignment, so it may take some time, but it's not something that we
can't work to accomplish. Either through an assignment with internal staff or looking at options,
because other cities enter these things as well, and maybe we can contract that
out. We will look at those options and move forward. Thank you.
And Kimberly had Teams'd me just to let me know that
Richard is looking into the Justice Court cost right now, so that assignment has been
given. So I don't think that necessarily— unless you want it
for tracking, I don't know that it needs to go on John's list. Justice Court
has been on there since since February of '24. So unless somebody
has moved to remove it in a meeting that I wasn't at, which didn't happen
because I'm at every meeting, it needs to happen. So let's just make it happen.
That one's good. And then as far as the justice court, I think that's fine
if he's looking into it, but I do think a conversation with the managers is
going to go a long ways. Um, the 2 managers as well as the county,
because what we were kind of looking forward is, uh, that precinct type
of— Well, do we— yeah, do we do a district court or municipal
But I think that's why you talk to them to see what their appetite is
and then talk to the county about which route. So that's what I'm curious about.
I don't know what their appetite is. I would be happy to do that.
And I know Jason's gonna— his eyes are gonna be like,
uh, it's gonna be nice. Jason and Mark and I get along just well.
Yeah, so now anything else
for legislative priorities? There was a comment from Councilmember Clark
about agritourism. What did you want to get put on?
Um, I— we've had people ask about pumpkin patches,
Christmas tree type lots in a neighborhood setting,
and farm-to-table things where
they could have a one-time thing where they use farm food to create a
special dinner and just make it a ticketed event.
Um, I'm not necessarily supportive
of making a Christmas tree stand in the middle of
a neighborhood, but I'm definitely willing to look at the farm-to-table stuff and
potentially even a pumpkin patch in the right area. So,
um, I would love council and staff
to work together along with our businesses and people within our community
that have the desire to offer agritourism and make it epic,
because I think it's yet another thing that Eagle Mountain Do
we really have the resources to target that as one of our main objectives?
That's my question. I'm not going to disagree with you that there
could be some benefit to it. But I mean, we sit here
and we moan and groan about the fact that we're not working on the Justice
Court, and we task people with, let's figure out how to do a pumpkin patch.
I just think we have to be careful in the asks that we make.
I agree with what you're saying, but in a lot of ways,
agritourism is a tourism is a component of economic development.
And looking at what other cities have already done
and bringing that for a discussion item doesn't feel like it will take
away from the duties of the other people who are working on code.
It feels like it's more of an economic development department
working with the state's Office of Tourism to find out what
best practices are. But if we want to put it on a back burner for
a while, I'm okay with that too. It's just— okay. I'm fine
putting it on there, but making sure staff is sort of prioritizing
what is on there. I mean, I'm sort of fine to put it on there
so it's on the radar still. So this is very
déjà vu. If you think agritourism, you think
things like the Cache Valley Cheese down
in Beaver, right? And getting your ice cream cone. You think of the Red
Barn. in Santaquin with— Red Barn. At Rolly's Red Barn. You think
of Maddox Steakhouse up in Perry.
You know, those are farm-to-fork, or they're growing their beef right there and all that
kind of a thing. Where— and having been through this,
like I said, it's very déjà vu— where it is the
most successful is when you have an industry like Basin Fruit Growers
or Cache Valley Uh,
their, their, the cheese and the milk production and dairies and whatnot,
when they come in and work with the city partnership hand in hand
to try to bring that forward, as opposed to a residential or
a one-off type of thing, which is, uh, so we're happy to
make it work and happy to bring code, and, and, and I've got a lot
of experience in this area. Um, uh, we just
want to make sure we're targeting the right thing, and do we have farms in
place that we are trying to take our milk and turn
it into, you know, stops on a freeway, that type of thing. You know,
that's, that's where it can be a destination. There's no doubt.
Um, I think one of the things that I'm thinking about is the fact that
I know of at least 2 farms right now that
are operating within our city limits that are already doing things like these,
and there's no code that addresses what they're doing. And I think
it's useful for us to look at that because everything's fine
until a neighbor complains to Neighborhood Improvement about it. And,
um, if it's something that council needs to
work on code for it, maybe Councilmember Whiting and I can
take it and run with it. I, I just— we have the issue
in our city right now, and I think,
um, yes, we have to prioritize stuff, but we also have to look at the
My personal preference with the small body here and knowing
that it's a little bit split, I would rather that that's a council
priority, knowing that we are thin-staffed. And if everything's priority, nothing's a
priority. That'd be my preference. But if you do want to
pursue putting it on a list and having staff work on it, then I'm fine
with that. I think that's a good idea. Councilmember Clark and I will work on
it. We'll bring you— we'll bring something to you, and we'll make it specific to
what's already existing in the city. Thank you. Okay, yeah, if we can do that,
that helps our staff load, I think, a lot. Uh, so anything
else for John? I think we're good. All right then. Uh,
I know you mentioned the seniors, uh, you met with them. Is there anything else?
Can I— I just— I want— they've rescheduled the chili cook-off for
October 26th at 5 PM. I just want to invite the council, and they're going
to have a kind of a Halloween-themed party there. But you have to come
and prepare your chili at the senior center or here at the
city hall, because I learned that you can't, you can't
make it at home and bring it. You have to cook it in a commercial
kitchen that's been checked and all that good stuff. So I'll give you more
details, but that's October 26th at 5 PM. if you just put that on
your calendars. And I've asked Dawn to send out an invite to each of you
so you're aware of that. That's all I have, Mayor. Thank you.
Okay, did you have any reports for liaison stuff?
Shop Fest is coming up, I think you mentioned, right? Well, that's Craig's report,
but the American Legion didn't meet this
last month, and I think maybe
we should look into that. I do, while they're not meeting, I think
we need to progress forward with the
veterans breakfast because I think that's something that we as
a city need to host and just
give it as a gift to our veterans and military families in
our community and kind of take that back under our wing. For some reason I
was thinking that was in the spring, but is it in November 11th. Yeah,
and I think this year it's like on November 14th or something, 'cause it's the
Saturday immediately following the 11th. So— If
there's no plans for that, then I think we should work with Dawn, and I
think she's worked on— I think it's on Dawn's radar. I just want
to keep it top of mind so that we're all preparing for
it. Once upon a time, the city council would go and make
the pancakes and help make the food and serve. And we'd bring Boy Scouts in
to help wash dishes and everything else. And then somehow along
the line, it ended up being a bunch of veterans serving
other veterans. And I think the point of the Veterans Breakfast was
for the community to serve our veterans. So. I've been
to that event for many, many years. Yes. I've cooked a lot of pancakes and
bacon. Any other reports? I got grease on my shoes.
Youth Council, anything? Youth Council's meeting this week, and I'll
be there with them. And, uh, Chamber's doing awesome. We've already talked about Shop Fest,
but they're just crushing it. They're doing such a great job.
Did Melissa already talk about, uh, liaison? I know the community services—
oh, thanks. The Community Development Board presented tonight.
Yeah, community Services Board, they presented tonight.
There's a list that they're going to bring back. I don't think we got it
on our working agenda, but they have a list of projects within the city.
We also had some reported initial RAP tax revenue.
I don't know if we're ready to discuss that.
I think Steve has some numbers there, but it sounded like the
RAP tax revenue received is coming in faster than maybe what
was initially I knew it.
Communicated when that was being voted on.
So positive things happening there. But I believe in the next working
session, Mayor, if we could add the Community Services Board to present
the list of topics so they can get some guidance from the council on where
to put their energy and focus to start laying down some of these projects in
our city. Let me ask you a question. specific like that, I'm fine if
it needs to be. But are you giving me a little leeway to say put
it on as soon as I can, or does it have to be next meeting?
They're kind of— they're, they're doing everything at a full sprint. So like,
I just don't know what the workload is yet because I want to make
sure that if it's— if the council brings it, then I'm going to put it
on, and it might be prepared for— I will say
that they wanted to put it— they want it they wanted to request putting it
on today's agenda, but because of everything else, they were okay
with putting it on a subsequent agenda. So I would say as soon as you
can humanly get it on there, Mayor. You make a note if there's room in
the next agenda, and if not, we can make sure we— 15 minutes.
15 minutes. Okay,
um, say again? Good for motion. Yep.
Wait, we got to make a Yeah, I move to—
I move the council adjourn to a closed session pursuant to Section 52-4-205,
subsection 1 of the Utah Code Annotated.
Second. Okay, we have a motion by Councilmember Whiting, second by Councilmember
Hewish. Councilmember Clark? Yes. Councilmember Wright? Yes. Councilmember Whiting?
Yes. Councilmember Hewish? Yes. Okay, that passes.
At 9:06, we will adjourn to closed session. Fantastic.
All right, it is 9:47, and we're back in our city
council meeting. And if everybody's okay, we'll entertain a motion.
Motion to adjourn. Second. Okay, we have a motion
to adjourn by Councilmember Whiting and a second by Councilmember Wright. All in favor?
Aye. That's unanimous, and we are adjourned at 9:47.